[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mm-hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
it was a day full of decisive games at
the u.s and u.s women's championships in
saint louis nothing changed at the top
of the open standings with so sevien and
lenderman sharing a half point lead over
a field that includes a surging fabiano
carawana carissa yipp is dominating the
event with her fourth straight win
definitely handling a reeling ashrita
eswaran who will pounce in the
penultimate round and who will fall flat
round 10 action coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to st
louis and the 2021 u.s championship and
u.s women's championship well karissa
yipp is dominating the women's event and
she could clinch it today with a victory
and a loss by her closest rivals but it
will indeed be a challenge as she's
being chased by eight-time champion
irina crush
in the open it is a free-for-all as
three players are tied at the top and
three others chasing them down who will
win it all well we're gonna go to the
exciting call with christian and yasser
the majestic gateway arch overlooking
the vibrant city of saint louis capital
of chess here in the united states and
host of the 2021 us chess championship
and us women's chess championships from
the studio at the st louis chess club to
call all the action i am your host grand
master christian kirilla and i'm joined
by my brilliant co-host grandmaster
yasser sarawan yasser always a pleasure
always a pleasure it's been so much fun
calling the action with you and maurice
i've been having a great time hello
everyone and welcome to our live
coverage of the 2021 u.s championships
we are in the championship rounds and
this is the penultimate round and all to
play for let's take a look at the
standings christian what do you have for
us in the open we're going to start with
the open section indeed we have three
co-leaders at the top wesley so sam
savion and alex lenderman following
closely behind three players also tied
for fourth position that is lanier
dominguez ray robson and one newcomer
fabiano caruana welcome everybody and in
the ladies in the ladies section we have
one lady that is just storming through
the event that is carissa yip leading
with seven points out of nine one point
behind his arena crush and katharine
named silva and gulrukh begin to
hironova one and a half points behind
the leader christian if the tournament
was to end today right now what is the
tiebreak playoff procedure well glad you
asked because we have a three co-leaders
at the top tied for first position if
the tournament would end today we will
have in the open section a rapid
round-robin game in 10 minutes with a
two-second delay
if after that round robin the players
two players are still tied those players
are going to play a two-game blitz mini
match that is game in three minutes plus
two seconds delay not increment
increment is used in the classical
portion we will have delay if three or
four players are still tied after that
rapid round robin well then we're going
to have another round robin this time is
going to be blitz game three plus two
delay what if only two players tied for
first after the round if only two
players are tied for first which is
quite likely well we will have a two
game rapid mini match
game in 10 minutes with a two second
delay if the players are still tied
after that 1-1 then we're going to have
the armageddon and what is an armageddon
well when the armageddon comes there's
going to be mayhem on the board white
starts with five minutes black starts
with four minutes
if the game ends in a draw then black
wins there's absolutely no delay no
increment is going to be madness gotcha
and what about our remaining schedule
well we've been playing a lot of chess
yesterday and we only have the
championship rounds today is round
number 10 tomorrow round number 11 last
round and if playoffs are necessary
those are going to happen on tuesday
october 19th gotcha and maurice ashley
is in studio to drill down further on
this penultimate round maurice always
good to see you my friend
always good to see you yes well it is
potentially history in the making here
at the championship lots going on that
we may remember for the rest of all time
and there are some things that you think
that's never happened before well indeed
we're going to take a look at some of
the remarkable things that are actually
being
transpiring now at the championship
let's first take a look at this big log
jam we have at the top there are six
players separated by half a point this
has happened only once before in a round
robin format and take a look it was our
very own yasser sierwan who was by
himself so already we've made history
with three players but he has at the
time was by himself at five and a half
being chased by a gang of thieves right
behind at five actually two of them
ended up catching him and that was the
one time we had a three-way tie
for that championship
indeed we've got players here who are
hoping that this won't be the case as
they try to separate themselves from the
pack let's start with one of our
co-leaders alexander lindemann who
hasn't lost the game this tournament but
he has to play against fabiano caruana
who's defeated him three times already
and fabi knows he's got to win this one
if he's going to have any chance of
competing for the title
another big pairing someone who was
leading the tournament after four rounds
ray robson he's been lurking and he
barely survived yesterday he will try to
take down the youngster john burke this
is a great parent for him and he could
possibly come back and join the leaders
at the top
and speaking of leaders it's sam sebian
who's played a magnificent tournament
more wins than anyone in the open
section and he's got to play against
wesley so what a great match up there
and take a look it's sam with the plus
score on wesley wesley knows that sam is
a very dangerous opponent indeed this is
one we'll have our eyes trained on from
the get-go and finally rounding out our
group of six is lanier dominguez who
missed the golden chance yesterday to
take a a tie for first coming into today
he will face off against jeffrey jean
who played a brilliant finish
to win against bruzon yesterday and take
a look again at the score it is jeffrey
with the plus score on his veteran
co-olympic team member
dominguez this one will be a difficult
one for dominguez to wade through as
well
now this is all nice as far as carissa
is concerned she's thinking you guys can
fight it out i'm trying to just win it
today she has
an amazing score after two wins in the
first four games she lost a very bad
game in round five but then it was bang
bang bang bang four wins in a row and if
she could somehow make it five in a row
today she will instantly make history as
the first woman ever
to win against four former champions as
she's playing nazi pakis who has won two
championships and not playing well in
this tournament but karissa does have
black so she will have a tall order
there and if she doesn't seal the deal
today she will have to face off against
katarina nemtsova who could potentially
catch her if carissa loses there's a lot
to play for and speaking of catching her
arena crush is only one point behind she
knows that she still has a chance she's
won eight titles she's looking for her
ninth she's got to take care of business
today against anya cervantes and then
she'll have a difficult matchup against
tatev abrahamian it's all going to be
difficult but the excitement as the
thoroughbreds have rounded the bend and
are going for the tape home
and there you see
the
chief horse in the lady section she
looks so calm so confident she knows a
win today it's a headlock she can
should be guaranteed at least a tie and
a playoffs no matter what happens but
she's not thinking about playoffs she
just wants to win it all maurice three
words
set the table for us in the pairings for
this penultimate round with the ladies
christians well the battles are
intensifying the stakes are higher and
higher we have sharovish versus foyshore
s warren versus zatonski by kiza versus
karissa if this is the marquee match-up
battle of a former champion against a
potential future champion nemtsova
versus tolhir gionova tied in fourth
position cervantes versus crush and
abrahamian versus and in the open
section the pairings please christian in
the open section these rounds are all
mouth-watering and this one in
particular the championship one of the
championship rounds it is shanklin
versus narudisky sam savion versus
wesley so that's a big one
robson versus john burke so important so
important as well jeffrey shong versus
dominguez nice this is versus bruce zone
and
lenderman versus car one fantastic and
as we're getting ready to start
the round of course the prestige of the
national championships is what it's all
about but there's also a lot of money at
stake as well christian they are indeed
playing for a lot of money in the
women's section we have a hundred
thousand dollar total prize fund 25 000
goes to the victor 18 000 second place
13 000
3rd place all the way down to 12th place
two thousand dollars nice nice
whoo
in the open section well we have a
hundred and ninety four thousand dollars
total price fun fifty thousand dollars
the first place thirty five thousand
dollars twenty five thousand dollars
going all the way to four thousand
dollars and nobody is going to win the
fisher bonus price of sixty four
thousand dollars because nobody remains
perfect exactly and they are off as the
opening bell
is underway for this penultimate round
this is where
your
i want to say determination
is so vital you've got to come to these
games absolutely absolutely zinc in i
was about to say
did i just see a potential groomfeld
[Music]
maybe a king
i'm telling you if abby was inviting me
with jesus
but instantly came g3 not the knight c3
bishop
we're going to have a king's indian i
have a feeling no c65s i don't think
we're going to see 665 yesterday when he
came for his interview fabiano that is
he said he's going to play today with
the black pieces he's going to try
everything he can in his
capability to win this one
by the way if that graphic is a move it
is it is against g3 c5 is definitely a
very good opportunity yeah uh if that
graphic that we saw earlier is correct
they played three games fabiano carolina
has won all the games oh yeah exactly
it's donald ross that's
guys he definitely wants to play a long
game to try to prove his superiority
over his opponent now think about
yesterday's game where talk about
dominant numbers wesley so was 4-0
against tanya noradiski and what did
dania do he saved a lost position as we
look at the games uh
there between sam savion and wesley saw
wesley just stepping out of the seat and
i see a london system what is it about
the london system with white that
suddenly everybody has started adopting
the london with you know why the one guy
named magnus carlson played it
leading the way
of course okay that's what that's all
about fashion is dictated by the best
players in the world and uh if if you
see
gary kasparov when he did something
well we trailed right behind
kramnik who said i'm flying to berlin
everybody follow right behind it's just
just
definitely uh fashion that does that and
now we see a very solid position also
difficult for wesley to get a winning
chance against the london because it's
so solid and sam knows he's got a
dangerous opponent in front of him but
sam has a plus score in wesley which i
found shocking
that's wesley so is that exactly like
what what what one win and three draws i
mean wesley so top five player in the
world
you know
behind
i don't think wesley's fifth in the
world right now but
but he's top 10 for sure and he's been
he's been number two in the world he's
been over 2 800 in fact so
for for sam to say yeah
i've taken care of business against him
right only wesley so exactly and i think
wesley himself mentioned that in one of
his interviews he said i have a negative
score against 77. he beated me in one of
the u.s championships exactly mentioned
when he was 13 years of age or something
like that that hurts
by the way fabi you guys were right he
is playing a king's indian and i've seen
him essay the system in the past with
the bishop
coming to f5 early it's an offbeat line
that isn't the most popular the highest
levels
uh in this game between lenderman and
fabi
um the system i've actually liked
for black as the old burn system with a7
a6 to be followed by b5 that was
also a favorite of gary kasparov but
this move bishop f5 takes a completely
different approach it's not the
traditional e5 you know knight d7 queen
c5 a kind of system that we saw that was
played by naji yesterday against begum
megham had this big big spatial edge
uh what black is doing with this move
bishop f5 is he saying i'm trying to
conquer uh the square knight e4 and we
just have knight g5 on the board so if i
if i put a bad move well bad move is
strong but if i put a soft move for
white rookie one with the idea if e4 now
we get a chance to see what is the
strategy
of
um
black he puts his bishop on e4 which is
kind of hard to get at that bishop isn't
easy atta easily attacked and it
neutralizes this bishop on g2
for example once again just some soft
moves by black if you think you're going
you know to nudge that bishop out of the
way well no that bishop can remain on
that square so we understand that knight
e4 is on tap for white and just to add
to your explanation yes sir for example
instead of c6 if black goes bishop to f5
and knight to e4 with the idea of
playing knight to e4 in one ply bishop
to f5 is going to be met by castle
knight to e4 and now there is this new
line with knight to g5
which is quite interesting and i see
that lenderman is playing something
similar with knight to g5 now knight
takes c3 b takes c3 bishop to c8
because this fellow is hanging precisely
and now white has the option of actually
going f4
remarkable f4 and we get this type of
position with e4 followed by f5 or e5
closing one of the two bishops is quite
an interesting line for uh white very
atypical absolutely
double pawns over here on the
queen side is compensated for by this
big uh control of space and
chances for an early attack
with uh as you say e4 and
f5 and the engines generally love that
position for white just because of the
space advantage and oops excuse me what
we're going to do is catch up with the
players here for just a moment because
alex did something quite surprising he
for me because i didn't know about this
idea of knight g5 he played knight g5 at
once right okay so he takes away the
control of e4 and he telegraphs the idea
that hey i want this big space advantage
how does the
theory if you will proceed from these
parts oh good question
i guess we will have to answer uh we
will have to ask why we brought
the database we have
databases to tell us but we also have a
move e5 on the board i think oh so fabi
was very familiar he was indeed with the
idea of knight g5 the idea of knight g5
is to play f4 while this e5 makes a lot
of sense you know at cross purposes you
are no longer playing for f4 well for
the most part the idea of knight to g5
is to go e4 and not allow black to get
that knight on e4
that control over the light squares in
the center which is so crucial for
flag's development is this tactically
not in oh this is probably not working
no no and that's why he played d5 after
e5 he responded immediately with the
move d5 oh we're barely keeping up with
the players because they are and yes
fabiano responded with a5
instantaneously
well i tell you if that became
in today's game with the idea of making
a full fl fight across the entirety of
the board he succeeded i mean this is
wow this is really a cool position he's
going to take some risks oh yeah he has
to
and uh
well uh
we we mentioned maurice and the database
and i see he's working hard to really
kind of drill down and let's just take a
quick look uh oh
the game between lanier and varder and
jeffrey is that queen's gambit
accepted
i don't want to call it the berlin
ending i don't want to call it the
queen's gambit accepted ending but i've
seen so many of these four and four in
two and two
uh middle game situations and i have
seen the number of drawn games through
the roof i mean the propensity to draw
for a draw in these positions is really
off the chart so
that's what's happening in that game and
then in the sam shanklin dania norenski
game we've got a traditional limbs of
indian let's jump again to one of our
marquee match ups uh just taking a quick
look at darus versus
this is it this was the one i wanted and
sam savion wesley so
this featured a london system with an
early c3 i've also seen
white players playing the london this
line of the linen system and developing
the knight quickly to c3 which is right
rather ironic sometimes they play queen
a5 check to provoke the knight to get
there and white voluntarily does it and
look at this
wasn't there a game with queen
no it was d4 takes
this particular game i think or
something very similar in the encounter
between shareevich and uh crush
yes earlier in the tournament i'm also
thinking that this was a game between
sam shanklin
dominguez where where i was uh pounding
the table for queen a3 and after queen
a6 somehow winning a pawn and we were
looking at those very surprisingly
castle i think was the novelty or
something along those lines in that game
okay
uh we do have oops excuse me let me just
uh refresh my board here just for a
second to catch up to so we do have
queen
a4
castles on the board
so
um sam
wesley
so once again
i mean the question for me that i always
ask is what about this pin i'm supposing
what can we what that's going to
immediately uh be met with knight to e4
immediately i believe so because that
defends also the queen on d6 so now i
can take on d4 i see i see so i don't
have
this is why i believe knight this is
much more uh precise than knight to d7
right 97 wouldn't defend the queen you
wouldn't be able to rip guys
away gotcha knight d7 defends the pawn
on c5 but not the queen on d6 but your
knight e4 on the other hand does both
and opens up the possibility of this
c5 takes d4 so once again we're looking
at a very forcing looking line but i'm
thinking you know again to my eyes i'm
seeing
an awfully weak pesky
this uh backward pawn on c6 and i tell
you that's going to get a lot of white's
attention absolutely tender loving care
as we say a lot of tlc coming in we will
keep an eye on this all-important
match-up and again when maurice told us
that sam savion has a plus score by the
way wesley queen a394 is on the board
yeah so we might be going that variation
okay we'll keep our eyes on this end
you've been drilling down on that uh
approach
by fabiano maurice what did you discover
well a couple of things the most
important takeaway though
is that this line is not that popular
and importantly so there are so many
different ways that black has tried to
play that it'll be it will be very
difficult for lendermen to guess exactly
what fabi would want to do against him
so he's got to have his own pet way of
playing
and then hope that it's just fine
because fabi has decided he's going to
go off into turgid muddy waters and keep
the game complex lots of pieces on the
board give his opponent some space but
then work it from there this blue bishop
f5 certainly has been seen quite a few
times but here white has several moves
and just to show you there's no one
consensus best move here knight h4 has
been played it's the favorite one 725
times 91 550 times b3 495 times almost
500 times even rook e1
371 times there's so many approaches
here for white the approach that was
chosen by
by uh
lenderman was the move knight to g5
uh which somehow i don't have on this
yes and it's moved 70 it's only 79 times
way down the list so not a popular
variation but this was chosen by ding
lorraine against one magnus carlsen a
couple of times in fact one time on the
tour
and one time here in this building uh in
a blitz game that they played and magnus
was able to win the game that was played
here so knight g5 and now again black
has choices h6 is a big choice but e5
was the move chosen by fabiano and then
we saw the move d5 the most popular move
here and again a diversion c5 could be
played c takes d5 could be played a5 is
what fabi did in that in fact chose and
now e4 is the most popular move and
black in this position has played either
bishop to g4 or bishop to d7 fabi has
played a novelty the move bishop back to
c8 has never been seen at least in the
database that we have here millions of
games eight million games bishop to c8
played now by fabi putting his opponent
in a new
position new territory and as you see
lenderman has paused because he's the
novelty is on the board there's more
bishop to c8
and it is i think precisely where fabi
wanted to be
again a kind of turgid mighty waters
type position who knows what's going on
it's all on you young man to try to
figure out exactly what to do against
this player who's played for a world
championship title and who is hungry to
win his second title we see there that
reaction means a move was played and
fabi's off to the board the battle is a
foot
marvelous stuff and
alex certainly knows what it means to
catch his opponent off guard in the
opening as we saw what he did against
ray robson but now the shoe's on the
other foot
because again as maurice has been saying
a lot of the moves are just
amorphous it just it is very hard to
nail down precisely what's what but i
always understood the move a5 but pardon
me christian yeah uh do you jump right
in i always understood the a7 a5 move
why did he play that
because he's staking out not only
territory on the queen side specifically
black wants to bring his knight from a6
to c5 once the knight lands
on the
c5 square
it doesn't want to be driven away by the
move b2b4 so the move a7 a5 is a signal
it says
i'm bringing the knight to c5 what are
you going to do about it and this move
h2 h3
boy talk about a hard move to guess i
would not have guessed that move would
and exactly this is leonard's point
because fabiano has been playing allah
temple up to this point right he knows
what he's doing he's analyzed this
position at home but maybe he missed a
timid move such as the move h3 and i
think this is exactly what lenderman is
trying to achieve in this position quiet
the game a little bit do not allow
fabiano to continue within his
preparation and i think he might have
achieved that and we see alex linderman
a very familiar pose it's like
he's got his throne
okay this is my chair he loves that
away from the board
he feels more comfortable what his
opponent is thinking and oftentimes i've
always appreciated it by the way with my
phone and gets up and walks away because
then it's sort of like i have the whole
table for myself and i'm not being
disturbed by anything that my opponent
might do by the way
takes d5 so maybe fabiano is still
within his preparation that would be
tremendous news for him
i can't imagine he's in his preparation
wow so
i don't believe in the move h first of
all bishop c8 is a new move bishop g4
as we said had been played before if you
can put that bishop g4 bishop d7 had
been played before and here white has
played f3 and then bishop the bishop
dropped back having induced a bit of a
weakness the main point being that the
g5 knight can no longer get back to f3
in one move and i think they put the
bishop on c8 yeah not d7 but
another move played is bishop instead of
f3 is queen to b3 after bishop to g4 and
that was this traditional theory and so
white is in comfortable waters here
i don't think fabi guessed that after
bishop to c8
that his opponent was going to play the
move h3
like that's not the you say okay what's
the what's the test of my last move
h3 no i mean
i couldn't imagine he guessed that
but
the the point you're making where i will
agree with you christian is
he's probably aiming for a certain
type of setup
which involves taking on d5 and putting
a knight on c5 at some point and playing
from here his pawns are radio on a5 so
that knight will be secure on the c5
square so he's got in mind a specific
type of setup as he's captured on d5 c
takes d5 obviously the most natural move
there and at some point he'll kick the
knight on g5 out but the pawn on h3 you
wonder why is that pawn there exactly
why did he play this move as there was
no knight g fourth threat the bishop
didn't want to go to g4 so i'm curious
why the h3 move was played in this
position it seems innocuous maybe so
that he could play bishop to e3 without
being hit by precisely tonight to g4
again it seems like a little bit of a
potential loss of tempo but
playing very slowly is lenderman and i
think
if anything i thought i think he wanted
to get out of fobby's prep
and say let me play something that may
not be
huge may not try to refute what you're
doing but let's get a just like just a
move on the board and i know it can't be
that bad to my position so it's not
going to be losing absolutely nothing
right asia is a useful move in most of
these setups and again we're going to
see this battle for the c5 square that
you are pointing out yasser
a problem for black's position is the b5
square that's going to be a weakness
forever because your pawn is already on
a5 that's the consequence of you playing
a7 to grade 5. b5 is always going to be
a hot spot for my knight i'm going to
land there at some point i'm going to
focus on your square c5 you're going to
land the knight on c5 and i'm going to
try to put as much pressure as possible
on that square rook to c1 queen to d2
maybe at some point try to get a3 b4 of
course it's not going to be very easy to
um play all those moves because whenever
i play the move a4 you're going to meet
that with a3 you're going to meet that
with the move a4 and take away the
possibility of me playing b4 as long as
black manages to keep the knight on c5
undisturbed is going to be perfectly
fine exactly nice kings and even with
bishop d7 and b5 or and or f5 let's just
jump back into the game of wesley so
because again uh
whoa
e6 e5
that looks like a very very novel
treatment vicious
vicious move that i see counter play so
for example knight takes pawn takes
queen takes i'm i'm trying to play an
ending of not just the fact that my pawn
up is why i want to get into the ending
but i'm thinking that the knight versus
the bishop ending might be a little bit
more fun
for for the knight rather than the
bishop
but
but this is the problem and of course
once again the surprising
lifetime score i mean when maurice
mentioned this i was like who in the
heck
has a plus score against wesley so in
america
uh
i can count the number i can count the
number on one hand i mean it's not that
many people and i don't think many of us
would have guessed sam savion is one of
those handful of people has a positive
score what i want to say is
wesley is making a very
intriguing uh pawn sacrifices
with this move the opening e6 e6 e5 so
we're just this is the game position now
i'm assuming that before the move e6 e5
the traditional database moves have been
to take and go into this ending that we
kind of just very very briefly
i do believe that castle was actually a
novelty if i'm not mistaken after queen
to a4 previously i don't believe that
knight to d7 or take on d4 were played
oh you think the novelty was casting so
i think so
okay then i stand corrected i thought
the novelty was bingo
look at that move okay so once again
we're just looking at uh what happens if
sam takes the pawn
black has a compensation
how big is that compensation in your
opinion
after a move i know it looks a little
ugly but bear with me for the moment uh
you've got some light squares but i've
got some it's it's compensation um and i
think this is exactly what wesley is
trying to achieve because i do believe
he's trying to win this game of course
all costs oh i think he's feeling some
pressure from his co-leaders even
burning bridges kind of costs could be
because he's going to have well he is
going to have white in the last round so
this is a little bit surprising i have
to say from wesley but the way he's been
playing
the first few moves the beginning of
this opening it pinpoints to that idea
well he came in yesterday in the press
conference or with postgame and he was
very despondent i mean
as maurice said uh he's interviewed
maurice you've interviewed wesley a
number of times he looked dejected it
was like man i could have had this
championship and i blew it and he was he
was not happy he was not happy he even
seemed angry yeah i mean oh yeah a
little there was a little edge there
in his voice in the expression i saw in
his face i've simply almost never seen
him he's normally serene right
contemplative
uh easy-going
definitely and and also
in some ways accepting of results he
says you know that's the way chess is
there's strong players here that's what
no yesterday he said i had three
different ways of beating this guy's
head
and he's like
what what am i doing you could just see
he's almost hurt by not landing the blow
realizing that he had a golden chance if
he had won that game he would be in
seoul first
he'd be at plus three he'd be playing
two players lower rated than he is by a
a big number right and so to see someone
who is just normally as we said serene
uh just generally philosophical about
his results and of course a two-time
former champion definitely a ferocious
defending champion fighter
to see him in that kind of mood was
shocking for us something we rarely see
and i can bet he's coming to today's
game
thinking all right i got a level of
score against you plus i want to be a
plus one in the tournament as well i
mean plus one over everybody else in the
tournament as well so let's play some
sharp chess and test the young man but i
had a feeling
this kid has been playing very well i
mean he's won more games as sam than
anyone else in the championship because
he did lose one game but he had that
plus one win
to show hey this is why i'm here he's
won three games in the championship
nobody else has done so but he didn't
lose one game
showing game he lost was also the
titanic absolutely titanic struggle so
i i don't know if you want to test
samsambian right now who's just playing
out of his mind with a great chance to
win it all if he could hit wesley this
round right he might he's certainly
going to be the preemptive favorite to
win the whole thing
wow and i see you've got the position on
the board if you might if you don't mind
me asking what does the engine think
about this exact current position i'll
turn it on and it says
triple zeros
i hate these engines
then why did you ask
why did you ask i had to because i had a
thing quiet turned off i'll turn it off
that yeah was gonna be some really
really crazy things but you did awesome
talk about a crazy thing by the way sam
has been thinking for quite some time in
this position 20 minutes about a
20-minute thing wow yeah
well
no not quite a 20 minute no that is not
that's not that's lander
fabiano okay
ah there we go yes down already 20
minutes on the clock has
he's still in good good shape i have to
say i believe wesley has definitely and
clearly won the opening battle in this
game
well in terms of surprising it's oh yeah
and i think he knows what he's supposed
to do in the next few moves he's not
burning any bridges by giving up this
pawn on c5 i think his compensation
after queen to g6 on the light squares
it's definitely sufficient and it allows
him to also potentially play for a win
it's not a lot on the board but you're
right the disparity of the bishop versus
the knight that one
uh
one major difference could lead
somewhere and he's playing aggressively
you don't see black pawns
sitting like this in the opening
very often
where we're just taking over the center
usually it's white who takes over the
center the way lenderman has done in the
game against fabi black's saying you
know what you're gonna give me all the
moves i'll just push them all up there
they go and i would like to show another
game just quickly
this one a huge game for the women's
championship as charissa with the black
pieces has essayed the rare hippopotamus
opening you know there are a lot of fun
names in chess we could probably go
through a list of them the orangutan the
frankenstein dracula variation i love
that the knife flick attack i mean just
like names upon names that are just like
what is that
but this was one of them the
hippopotamus the idea being that the
hippopotamus crouches below the water
and then don't mess around because it'll
suddenly show up and take you down well
she's done so by putting knights on d7
pawn and b6 a6 pawns on g6
and h6 as well these center pawns not
fighting for the center
black is always ready with some kind of
push whether it be d5 or e5 depending on
what it does and if white plays d5 then
black will bypass generally with the
move e5 and vice versa e5 then d5
there's so many ways to go
in this opening the fact that she chose
an opening that's not super solid i
think that almost any top player in her
situation with the pointley will say i
got black i'm going to play my best most
standard opening that gives me a decent
position make a draw and then look to
win with white in the next round or just
look to see how my chasers are doing
because with a draw nobody can catch her
in at least in this round with a draw to
play this cagey opening i think
the the classical players would say
not the right choice at this moment yeah
i would say not at all
very very recently it must have been one
from one of the magnus
carlson
tour online games
nepa with black was in a kind of a
must-win situation and he
came out with a hippo and i actually
think he achieved his objective from the
opening a very risky choice right i
wanted to say in her situation no reason
what brought her to the party by the way
by the way take a look at naji's clock
however because she's already up 20
minutes
by making this choice she's giving naji
plenty of rope what do you want to do
you want to castle king side you want to
castle queen side you want to play d5
you want to play what do you want to do
like
this is not something that i think knows
she could have expected no
and it's on the board it's a bit weird
and now she's trying to figure out okay
what am i supposed to do you see her
sitting up there in her chair the
seconds are ticking away now she's not
playing well in this tournament
and if she doesn't handle her business a
win by carissa could literally end
this whole tournament with a round to
spare if arena does not win her game by
the way arena is black against talia and
that game
will pull up here and italia with the
space advantage in this position i think
most of us would like to have white here
those who like to dominate with space as
we see a morocci bind the bishop outside
the structure knight d5 could happen at
any point white's
it's hard to see how white loses
this game i mean this is this one wife
of choice no question about it
and so a loss by irina
and a and a draw a result even a draw
would put her in a fantastic situation
but you know it's kind of strange when
you put up this big board
yeah the bird's eye there are
seven games of import
seven out of the twelve wow in this
penultimate round three in the women's
section and four in the open
that's that's unusual why stop seven
games that are extremely significant
because in the open there's six players
who are tied
or within a half a point of the lead
while on the ladies side here three
players actually they're four players in
the mix and two of them are playing each
other right now so i guess we should
stop in on that game as well the one
between
between nem silva
and
and uh
jonova so this one is only in the
opening seven moves in and already name
silva has burned a lot of clock as well
you can tell this round is important
guys because they're burning clock on
key games and as you see here there's
only four players mathematically in the
mix right everyone else is gone naji is
not going to win it's everybody on four
you're not catching the leader you're
done your tournament's over you're
playing for pride and a little extra
cash but the four players we see there
at the top they all have a mathematical
outside chance
to be sure for the ones who are tied for
third but they're still in the mix to
win it all so these are huge games we
have at the top of this table and i'm
seeing a very similar situation in the
games of the leaders in both the open
sections as well as the women's section
the leaders wesley sews in particular
and carissa are putting a certain
psychological pressure on their
opponents put yourself in sam savian's
shoes your adequate leadership position
in a very very one of probably the most
important event of your life you're in a
great position but you are playing with
the white pieces you feel like you don't
risk too much losing against the players
such as wesley so wesley doesn't take
too many risks but now you play against
wesley so and he blitzes out this
variation with e5 pawn sacrifice he
looks unperturbed right now wesley he
looks confident in his preparation i
believe we see a knight x e4 d takes e4
and now you will probably have to accept
that pawn sacrifice or last moment to
bail out and go castle hide the king
in in all of those cases i'm going to go
queen g6 and then
h3 and wesley is playing for the light
square attack
and sam
he doesn't like it
he doesn't like he doesn't like it
because if he loses this one yeah
bye-bye podium potentially oh yeah oh no
he's going to play with the black pieces
in the last round and karissa ipp is
putting psychological pressure on her
opponent as well nasi pakise who's been
having a disastrous event exactly not up
to her standards she came here to win
the event
she's a champion she was a champion
twice in this event right now you're
trailing by three points
yeah and not pretty not pretty no chance
to win by the way she played three has
to win she played age three and
instantly bishop b7 bishop carissa is
not message tradition knows this the
moves i know to play i'm going to play i
tried to essay this myself with black
and one of the plans for black is to
play king f8 to g8 to h7 because you
can't
castle because your h-pawn is constantly
hanging so h3 is a waiting move to say
where do you plan to put your king but
black said i got bishop b7 where do you
plan to put your king
white doesn't want to wait to spend time
castling early because that will
telegraph to black exactly where white
is going to go and also with the pawn on
a4 already then it's tricky for white to
go on that side because there's always
going to be a b5 kick that potentially
opens up the queen side so this is where
naji is a bit looking a bit confused as
to what's the waiting move to play here
to to make
her opponent decide what to do with her
formation because they're sort of
running out of useful moves
other than castles
um
help me out here guys i i think i came
across a book i
this might be embarrassing it might be
in my library the black lion the black
lion and i thought it came from this
hippo because i have in my mind this is
williams yeah
the black line i'm not sure if it's a
book or a
dvd and i remember it was sort of like
in this exact moment like what you were
saying maurice like white's made all of
her kind of developing moves that she
can maybe she can toss in one more move
rook d1 before you know black has to
make also some kind of a committal move
so everybody's waiting for everybody to
castle and the idea was the black lion
emerges after the move g6 g5 and the
idea is that this knight gets to go
swinging over here eyeballing these
squares
and as you say a d5 can kind of get met
by e5 but if the knight is already on
the g6 square
then there can be some kind of king side
play very intriguing that's part of the
game that's part of the position as well
and h3 as a result you see you play the
a4 move
right that creates a hook on that side
so b5 is always a hook and h3 does the
same thing h3
invites the g5 potential hook on that
side as well so right now
uh it seems
carissa is well within
her preparation her understanding of
this setup it's definitely cagey it's
tricky and it catches players with white
out there and it's important to note
that
naji is not an e4 player she's not a
traditional e4 player she's more
traditional d4 player so she's got this
position because when she played d4
opponent played g6 and she was like all
right then i'll just take the center and
now she's taking on this type of
formation
and suddenly she's sitting there going
what am i supposed to do like how do i
get at black structure and black if you
know it as black you'll know what moves
to make i mentioned for example this
maneuver king f8 all the way to h7 is
one idea in the position and you know
it's black also any e5 any pawn break
attempted palm break in the center is
immediately met by a side slide if you
will and say nope not not going to be
good for you to go into this setup and
you'll have to to get a break for a
white you'll have to reorganize your
minor pieces to get the f4 break or the
c4 break against that center formation
the knights are in the way now even the
bishop on c4 is in the way of a c4 break
it's not easy to play as white so not
being familiar is huge and we're seeing
that on the clock right now as her
seconds are
are turning to minutes ticking away for
naji as she is now down almost 30
minutes on the clock you got the white
pieces against an opening that's
supposed to be a little suspect you're
down 30 minutes and you don't know what
to do right great sign for carissa no
question and she's played so swiftly
throughout this event i mean a lot of
players coming in from the women's
championship having a post-game
interview as mentioned specifically
carissa and anna sherivich as being very
very swift with their moves we'll keep
an eye on that i just on that game i
want to also go to the arena game where
are you arena that would be
no third target yeah right there we left
it it was that
um
i want to say
meroxie bind
position
and we're kind of by the way confused
arena is not the king's indian player no
let's see what was the opening sequence
seeing a lot of players with the black
pieces try to win in this round
oh it came from the same issue she's got
to win taking on well risks that you
have to take if you want to win a
championship right at this point and
look at this very peculiar
move order by arena to get into this
miroxi binding this early bishop
e6 i must say i'm not a fan
of this specific move in this specific
move order i actually like oh my gosh
there was a
gentleman from the soviet union and he
was considered along with gary kasbarov
as the cream of the generation his name
was lefsakis
and lev i believe tied for first in a
soviet championship and he was
and he i saw one game of left sakes that
made a really powerful impression on me
was an early b6 knight d7 knight c5
maneuver
against the
specifically the moroccy bind where
white had played f2 f3
and um he wanted he won a model game so
in this particular position i'm not a
fan of
move bishop e6
let's see what happened knight d7 but
not with b6 the reason why i'm not a fan
is i think this bishop is actually
misplaced
and as well because you can get hit with
f4 f5 potentially also knight coming to
d4 precisely in some lines that's
precisely right the thing i think i fear
the most
is the knight getting hit the knight
coming and potentially going here and i
think generally whenever you put the
knight on d5 she's gonna capture that
she's going to take on d5
yeah and then she has to play right that
kind of a king's indian position but
another point that you just mentioned
was like f4 uh you don't want to get
your your your bishop trapped with an f5
and a5 on the board we'll keep an eye on
that and by the way i really like what
sam savion is doing right now yeah how
let me switch
this difficult situation in his game he
played the move queen take c5 queen to
g6 accepted the pawn sacrifice
and after that they move knight to d2
offering the pawn back right take it but
allow me to cast allow me to get my
pieces in in play well this is what we
were hoping for in this kind of a
penultimate round this is a real donny
brook because
kings could be on opposite flanks
maurice back over to you and the kacha
game you want a donny brook you better
take a look at this one this one went
wild immediately as katja namsova is
looking for the win against tokyo genova
but i get the feeling that she is just
risking way too much with the white
pieces i know christian is smiling
looking at this position knight of six
d4 ed4 e5 d5 bishop b5 and now this move
knight d7 not the most common move in
this position of knight e4 has been
played at least 10 times more 94 is a
typical move here knight to d7 carter by
surprise she castled and after bishop to
e7 she decided to play an enterprising
style with the move c3 very few games in
this line and actually a good try a very
good practical try in this line this
will easily catch her opponent off guard
to make this kind of gambit it turns out
that after d takes e3 knight takes c3
white has great compensation this is
sort of like the uh carissa yip school
of sacking pawns for play this would
have been perfectly fine for white also
black with good defense could hold here
but still this is the kind of style that
you would expect but as you see there on
the board this is not the position we
actually have we actually have the move
queen takes d5 that was played and queen
takes d5 is a different kind of
direction completely never before tried
knight takes c3 was the move that was
trying before taking on d5 with the
queen it looks like it's pressuring this
night the question becomes after takes
takes and castles do you really want to
take this piece or that is to take and
get your pawn back after rook to b8
tempo on your bishop next move bishop b7
tempo on your queen and every move is
working in black's favor you got your
pawn back but it doesn't seem to be
leading to any sort of initiative if
anything it's blacks that black's at
getting the initiative in this position
i don't like this play for white at all
queen takes d5 looks like a way too
aggressive move bringing the queen out
it's not even like you're threatening
anything like bishop c6 is just not a
threat nobody cares about giving back a
pawn
in a position where you're giving up the
two bishops and play for the other side
so this is almost easy peasy
for
uh beg him in this situation to make
decisions here it's not a hard decision
unless you fear some kind of attack like
takes takes and castles that maybe maybe
e6 is a move but you you just get the
feeling right now that this is not going
to work out in white's favor almost just
natural play here you're sort of burning
all your bridges with just the bishop
attacking and the knight and rook still
locked in this knight could get a couple
of tricks it's not going to be enough i
almost feel like i could blitz out the
next few moves and ask you knight g5 is
not possible 95 goes nowhere queen 86
goes nowhere
i think very important is for gulruk
begin to see that after rook to d1 she
always has the idea of just playing the
move knight to f6 this position you mean
correct yeah right you move your knight
out the way and that's going to be all
she wrote matter of fact but that's
that's that line you're talking about
christian
i feel like if i was black i want to
punish white for this kind of over
aggressiveness
but she does white does have some
pressure
in this position right now
just to point out some funny variations
maurice if you might uh instead of this
move c3
the move the main move in the position
is to just recapture the pawn after
bishop takes c6
b takes c6 knight takes d4
now what do you guys think the best
movie in the position is right now
knight b8 knight b8
but i
knew that you did you did i knew that
knight b8 i knew it from a french
defense kind of thing we've that c6 c5
is embarrassing
while bishop b7 uh allowed
it's all good for but knight b8 covers
c6 it covers e6 very important tempo
on b2 by the way so we have bishop takes
b2 on the board and again these kind of
gambit formations for white knight takes
season 3
you don't lead with your queen it it
just doesn't work out unless you've got
extra pieces and the fact that she
didn't play knight takes c3 she clearly
guessed with c3 she said let me play
this kind of it was it's a nice idea you
bring your night out you may not get a
big advantage but it's reasonable to
play but to take with your queen and
hope something's happening right this
the c6 knight is not under threat
nobody's worried about you taking this
piece and if i'm not worried about you
taking this piece i'm just going to get
out the middle right here and play chess
right now everything works in black's
favor after that yeah exactly put the
queen back on d1 put the knight on b1
on the d5 square and everybody's oh man
both of these ladies are looking for a
win oh absolutely because if they don't
win yeah they know that tournaments no
chance to win the tournament exactly now
you started us out on the wesley sew
game sam savion you really
by the way the current situation and
that's why the katya versus bacon
christian is such a crucial matchup and
somebody wants to go six and a half
exactly nazi pakistan tied for fifth
she's quite far behind yeah
one and a half points but you're also
one and a half points behind carissa
right right now so this matchup is
crucial for that podium position exactly
and you're just saying come on
knock karissa off her perch at the top
you mentioned the game uh sam savion
wesley so you mentioned that you were
really happy with the decision that i
liked
with
now we think that it was either that the
castles move or the e6 e5 move that was
the novel approach by wesley giving sam
a challenge and you liked in particular
christian that
sam answered wesley's challenge by first
of all accepting the i think it was the
first world champion wilhelm science who
said the best way to refute a gambit is
to accept the game
okay he accepted pawn number one but now
he saw this move queen g6 he saw
that castles would walk into a vicious
attacking move bishop h3
uh he saw that after the move rook g1
compensation abounds
maybe this bishop might just settle on
the d3 square maybe rookie i like this
move because right now with the knight
on b1 you are almost forced to play b3
you don't have the long castle defending
that pawn on b2 i think this is a
crucial detail absolutely i i couldn't
agree with you more and that was why you
were so enthusiastic about the move
knight d2
rook b8 question mark castles is exactly
what white is hoping to achieve he
hasn't injured himself in any any
measure
queen takes g2 on the other hand i think
is
uh once again castles exactly and then
after castles well let's rip
and i suppose the answer to that is
ripping greg how you
i mean i'm falling under the influence
of ray uh if i could also make another
suggestion here for for wesley what what
about this one
if you take with a c pawn then the
desirable queen takes looks a lot better
than my previous line i'm not hanging
the e5 pawn if you do go for one of
these
rook g1
kind of attacks
um
i do have the move f7 f6
i don't i want to go forward with my h
pawn oh with the h rook sorry yes of
course you do ahg-1 because i want to
preserve that rook from d1 to come to f1
i think you make an an excellent case
for for rook
d e pardon me for using the h rook um
my goodness it's going to be a wild one
what does the president of the pawn
gruppers association do when he has two
potential pawns to capture normally you
want to capture the one that's closest
to the center don't tell me you're not
going to capture either oh i'm going to
capture something but i if i capture
this one
now i really understand very well why
you waited
to use the other rook i'm going to
invite you to capture another one yeah
of course which i actually think you're
forced in now i mean right i i i'm here
i'm there i got it and now knight thinks
knight takes c4 exactly so f6 no idea
what's happening in this position uh
well i do i think it's uh a challenge
for wesley i mean i don't think it's
it's lost or anything of that nature but
i understand he's the one
who who has the initiative but back over
to you and do we call it the hippo or
the black lion
well whatever you call it
carissa needs to remember exactly what
she's supposed to do here because you
play an opening like this it's not
obvious what your pawn breaks are what
your your forward movement is what this
what's your plan you have got your king
stuck in the middle of the board at e8
and how do you get it out the middle
properly when you see that white's
pieces are poised waiting to figure out
how this game is going to open the right
way now
if she remembers
properly that pawn on h3 is a small
tempo loss usually white puts a rook
doesn't play h3 castles puts a rook on
e1 and then we get into a different type
of position but this pawn on h3 gives
carissa a very concrete operation yes
she could play king fa very
rarely tried in this moment g5 she could
go for as well but this is the trick in
this position
that
people who play the hippo have to know
the timing at this exact moment says i
can play this move knight f6 and
pressure this pawn i get a full tempo to
get away with it
now if you try to advance thank you very
much for this square and my knights are
happy some trades will happen and i'm
also aggressing your bishop and what
what am i to worry about here thanks so
much for the advance
if instead after knight of six you play
the move d5 why quick black quickly
shifts and plays e5 thank you for that
advance and white's clear plan is to
play somehow b4 c4 and c5 that's what
you would do with the pawns pointed in
this direction
if you decide to switch and play knight
h2 saying well i'll play for f4 here at
the right moment not only will you
potentially open up this bishop for for
black also a knight on d7 could go to e5
black could also say you're not getting
that move in not so fast and it's not so
easy for you to exploit this f5 square
this bishop will reroute itself and
black will be the one playing on this
side now he's gonna go to g6 and 4 black
has
many simple ideas and by the way thanks
for the hook on h3 because we'll be
attacking you with g4 potentially as
well so this is the standard recipe in
this position
for for carissa
i say it's a standard recipe it's the
first time she's stopped and gone into a
deep dink in an opening that she
intentionally prepared naji now away
from the board and karissa's sitting
there wondering what should i do and if
any weakness we've seen in her play
it's
in those kind of positions where direct
play isn't really possible
she starts to make some kind of strange
moves and you say way now is positional
time
that's some place where she has had
trouble she did lose in round five in
that kind of situation where she was
already worse
but
here we see
uh a game missing
the producer's taking away one of her
wins what's going on she won four in a
row not just three
that's uh i'm sure her her friends and
family are saying what's going on oh oh
okay updated
the updated graphic and
there we go apparently we have to pay
for these graphics
four in a row she's in first place by
herself she does not want to lose this
game it would be disastrous and she's
far from it for sure of course but
when you play the hippo you take a
chance you roll the dice make sure you
know it
make sure you know the main themes of
this opening is not one of those you
just set up and then go hmm i wonder how
you play this position no
idea and i think she
drew some inspiration from her game
against shareevich she had no question a
similar structure of course it wasn't
the pawn on b6 the pawn was on c5 but
still the same structure on the king
side now she looked at that game she was
like i was in deep trouble yet she was
but if i survived that
i can survive anything and i can survive
anything but what kind of policy is that
against the players that struggle
i'm not saying i'm not commending her
why would you go into this outcome
with that mindset well check this out
though maurice because er carissa
exactly in the position that you've set
up on your board i agree with you
wholeheartedly that knight f6 is the
most
uh desirable type of move but after
bishop d3 or you know keeping the
tension now if you put the knight back
on d7 for a second i think carissa is
saying to herself you know i've actually
got my opponent thinking early she
doesn't really know how she's going to
break
i've got this flexible set up with my
knight on d7 i'm thinking carissa wants
to play the move king f8
and king g8 and king h7 and say two and
say to naji
you go ahead and force the action so
unfortunately for her she's got two
plans and maybe she's not settled in
them
well
that's all well and good yes
you know i mean it's a great theory just
like that
i want the commanding for a great theory
like hello hello i mean she has an
alternate move as well to be honest she
has a fourth she a third move where she
could play for this move which is eight
which ain't the most fun position to
have to play and go into this position
and say you got the two bishops let's go
uh potentially an id5 idea
you don't want to do that when you have
your bishop so yes you're right she's in
this moment but i just i just feel like
when you play this opening you you
should know the nuances and
it's it's not the easiest road to
equality
is she playing for equality i guess not
if anything we've seen in this
tournament it's the black pieces where
she's been vulnerable she had that
position against begin where she got
toasted and then she got that position
against anna where she was getting
toasted and roasted all kinds of ways
before she made a very pro
vicious comeback and
demolished her opponent and won the game
so if anywhere she's a little bit
vulnerable it's here this is her last
black
if she could just navigate this game
yeah i don't see anybody catching her
she's gonna have white against them so
in the last round and the way she's
played with the white pieces it's been
spank city
come here and take this beat down so
this is the game as we see she this is
her road ahead
this is it
if any damage is still going to be done
it's right here
can pickkinsey play spoiler you heard
uh tatev abrahamian coming here why not
well if i'm not going to win the
tournament
spoiler is what you got left right
you've got to you've got to make
somebody upset and nazi would walk in
here with a smile on her face saying
yeah i beat the tournament leader when
she really needed it that shows uh
that shows that i still can fight
exactly turning our attention to the
game of alex lenderman one of our
tournament co-leaders he's up against
the tournament pre-tournament favorite
fabiano
very intriguing decision by both players
first of all i thought that the knight
was going to come to d7 to fight for
over control of
the c5 square no fabby took a different
approach he said i'd like to play bishop
d7 developing my pieces thank you very
much
and i'm going to play for b5 and i
always thought in these structures where
i'm playing against a king's indian and
my opponent has a pawn on a5 i'm really
really really reluctant as white
to play the move
a4 you are yes interesting okay because
i'm really
afraid that once oh pardon me that was
not the right move that was a milestone
i had that in my mind for another
variation after the move rook c8 i'm
thinking black plays knight c5 and now
that whole b2 b3 a3 b4 the creepy crawly
slow moves of fighting uh contesting the
square c5 is gone so i think an
important point to make right now and i
thought you were going to go a different
route i thought you're going to say that
you're going to try to transfer the
knight from f6 to c5 and leave that
knight from a6 to go to b4 now that the
move a4 is under like something like
bishop e a and i was going to challenge
that because i've seen these knights
they look pretty they do but they don't
do anything they don't in general and if
you don't have a knight on the king side
then
sometimes
yeah yeah exactly so yeah
i we we we shared the same hymn book uh
that uh
and that was why i was advocating for
rook c8 knight c5 funnily enough if any
police belongs on b4 normally speaking
you don't like leading with the queen
let me make a bad move if you if you
don't mind just
these aren't terrible moves but they're
not the best for white uh queen to b6
oftentimes somehow the queen is actually
nicely placed on b4 by the way don't
forget the e pawn could be remain
vulnerable after h7 h6 that is a game
we've got to keep our eyes on i think a4
was a very important strategical moment
oh absolutely back to you maurice and
the katja game we saw katarina silva
lose the lead
after round seven
then she finally lost the game
in round nine right
that's the slide
officially in the books we call that a
slide like you're live
it's not official but i just made it up
you're going downhill she's going the
wrong way
she was doing so well to that point
before she lost the lead but she still
was playing very well she didn't lose
the game she just
got surpassed by carissa then she lost
the game
that psychologically starts playing
within your head and now it looks like
she's trying to lose again not on
purpose but this is what's happening to
her she's played this very suspect
variation
with queen takes d5 knight c3 we would
have applauded her bravado but queen
takes d5 you just don't lead with your
chin that's just not what you're doing
that's what she's doing with her queen
and after castles
this is exactly what you do with the
black pieces get the king out of there
and say you know you're coming at me
really fast but you're going to run out
of steam and by the way we should point
out this line again this is nothing
rook d1 and christian the first move
that came in my mind you said 96 was 95
right this is the one i really liked
because i'm touching your knight on this
square also hitting your queen all the
way through if you play rook takes we'll
start with a check hello then we'll take
on this square and say thanks for the
two bishops and by the way uh you're
still down a pawn
show me what you got you're lost in this
position what did she do instead of
bishop c6 after castle's winning her
pawn back she could have played this
line takes takes takes we talked about
this get your queen out of there and now
if bishop to b7
just just tried over try to fight just
try to make this position work it's even
material it's not so bad you shouldn't
have given up your light square bishop
but hey life is life and play this
position you're worse but keep it going
instead
she played knight to c3
she's down a pawn right now
and black has options the best one is
knight to c5
just playing chess more the more to
marry let's get the pieces out what
you're going to do don't try to win my
pawn did you try to win my pawn what did
i say don't try to win my pawn your
queen has no way back home except b5 and
bang thank you very much for that skewie
manui and you're gonna drop material
here this is great everything is going
black's way right now
because of this injudicious queen takes
d5 capture and it looks like christian
is sitting there trying not to get too
happy as his charge is looking very good
right now it's a good position of course
it's what we wanted out of this opening
an imbalanced position that's why we
decided to go this route with knight to
d7 and not knight to e4 because kachka
did play this variation earlier against
megan lee and we saw that early night to
b3 that was not good
so it felt like she doesn't feel these
type of positions that well so we
decided to go this round knight to d7
maybe we'll surprise her it seems like
it did nevertheless this position is
still a game white has the central
squares central files if you manage to
avoid that queen trade knight to c5 is a
key move right absolutely because if you
stray away and go knight to b6 for
example then the queen gets that e4
square
and once it's centralized once it has
its eye on the king's side h7 then it
becomes a bit more difficult knight c5
key move if she sees this one i do
believe that the tides will turn in her
favor knight c5 i think big advantage
for me it looks like big advantage black
i love the material but i also love the
fact that pawn on e5 is going to be
blockaded by bishop on e6 i take black
in that position every day by the way
carissa found knight six she did she
took her a little while a little while
she's back on track and forcing her
opponent to make a decision this move
knight to f6 on the board and so
concrete is this move hitting the pawn
and you've got three ways to my eyes to
go
you've got e5 you've got to consider d5
you've got to consider and bishop d3 to
consider
all three moves having completely
different characteristics taking the
game on
just a very diverse paths completely
this is what you want to do enforce your
opponent who's not familiar with the
position to go into a deep think and
make responsible decisions right at this
moment and if white plays bishop d3
she's backing down a little bit to say i
i still haven't figured out what to do
maybe i'll just play bishop d3 and put
some rooks on the files and and test
your king sitting on e8 what are you
planning to do
there's also a c5 break she has to watch
out for but there's all kinds of breaks
white constantly has to calculate to see
whether or not they work by the way
there is another line she has to look at
bishop d3 d5 e5 knight e4
comes in as another move as well so so
much to look at in an unfamiliar
position i think carissa having found
knight f6 now has naji exactly where she
wanted her
very very good point again turning thank
you maurice no seriously that is a very
nice explanation of what is going on in
the leaders
lady the lady leaders group i just
wanted to say that wesley
played in my view a much better move
than i was advocating he actually took
immediately on a d4 and said i want to
clarify how you're going to recapture if
you recapture with the e3 pawn or the c3
pawn i'm going to capture on g2
and this provoked queen takes d4 we're
up to date with the players
said okay you know what
my threat to the g2 pawn is not going
away
and i know if i take the g2 pawn i'm
inviting an attack along the half open g
file
i'm going to play this steady calm move
rookie 8 which he has just done i'm
defending my pawn on e4 i do i'm waiting
for your king to go queenside okay once
your king goes queen side now
and he's almost forced to go queenside
because if you go kingside bishop h3
once again comes on the board and you
lose the exchange yes and maybe even
worse than that everything's suddenly
gone wrong too from white's perspective
so castles is definitely out
and uh
well i mean sam is actually still in the
fire i mean
actually
like white a lot a lot okay please tasty
was a bad move is that what it is the
engines prefer queen takes g2 as the
right move in that instead of rookie a
instead of no instead of it takes d4
instead of taking on d4
really yes how is
uh let me go back queen g2 long castle
queen f2 yep
and what did you guys play here
e5 i think we were looking queen takes
e5 but i'm not 100 queen takes e5 queen
takes e3 the engine don't see a danger
here as black will go to 8-6 and defend
the position although humans will look
at it and go
wait a minute but according to the
engine black is fine here here castles
is what he played he's just castled out
of it and the engine suggested bishop to
g4 f3 and the game goes but they just
feel like white is the one with the
slight edge here at least a 0.5 edge
how much is that against wesley
i don't know
we can't say wesley we know that wes is
a great defender but white is still
doing just fine in this position looking
to show that his knight and the dark
squares will be better than the bishop
on those light squares we do have
castles on the board as you uh
recommended maurice
by the way we're just going to be uh
turning towards our break christian as
we do here little commercial spawn
there yesterday i have my very own
autographed
chessboard of all the players of these
championships
and it's gonna
you might be able to zoom in but
essentially trust me on this it's a
piece of chess history exactly as we've
got all of the
signatures of the players of these 2021
u.s championships
and the material is a final
yeah sorry it's not silicon it's it's
vinyl
it's vinyl maybe that's inaccurate but
it doesn't like vinyl it's a very nice
this is something you just simply want
to frame by the way i kind of consider
these things like works of art with all
of the signatures of the players very
very beautiful very limited this is not
yet available
stl.com but it is coming soon so keep an
eye on
cuboutiquestl.com we will have this
autograph vinyl boards collect a piece
of chess history and well showcase it in
your library for example exactly
and we have a special birthday song who
is it who is it
one of our production staff look at that
never seen him look so happy
all of 80 years old isn't he remarkable
looking great
looking great for an 80 year old happy
birthday
i think i got some laughter
yes
for 80 he's amazing
it looks great another year older
exactly we'll see you on the other side
[Music]
if you have kids you already know st
louis has a ton of fun stuff for
families to do like the magic house or
the science center and if you really
want to be a stellar parent come see all
the new stuff there is to discover at st
louis union station with a new mirror
maze light shows and the 20-story st
louis wheel it's enough to make any
parent feel like a star
st lou
always exploring
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
[Music]
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles
[Music]
occur it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
and active communities
it sounds like life
and it's what you hear
when you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
ascension
a st louis public radio journalists most
precious possession isn't a notepad
camera
microphone or recording device their
most precious possession
is credibility
a journalist's work revolves around the
truth
finding it
verifying it
and reporting it
great journalists work hard to find the
facts and put those facts into context
examining all the arguments and
including differing opinions
amplifying fascinating voices from our
community
telling captivating stories
offering facts that may have been
omitted
we work every day to earn your trust for
news turn to st louis public radio
[Music]
we all know st louis is a championship
sports town from the 11 time world
champion cardinals to the stanley cup
champion blues
but i bet you didn't know about all the
championship places there are to get out
and play here like the world chess hall
of fame westport social and topgolf and
now even our own mls team so whatever
sports your team is into you can always
bring out your a game in st louis
oops sorry st lou is always exploring
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to our continuous
coverage here at the uss championship we
are in the championship rounds round
number 10 it's heating up but we also
have a segment that we enjoy doing in
between these breaks brilliancies versus
blunders yes indeed it's a recap of the
highlights and shall we say the low
lights of round nine and we had a number
of them uh beginning with our blunders
and sometimes in chess we have this
situation of we we call mutual blindness
so a co-blunder if you will by both
players here in this game fabiano as
white has a winning advantage that he
can
drive his advantage home with the move
h7 h5h6
which is likely going to transpose into
the game in the game a howler a real
blunder was made by fabi as he retreated
his queen queen f3 and after queen f3
well rook b4 h6 and the transposition
to the variation took place in fact
darush
missed a golden opportunity
with the move bishop takes h5 what would
have happened after bishop takes h5
queen takes h5
g
g
7 g6 if the queen drops back now wait a
minute now we're in the bishops of
opposite color
situation this bishop is on this
diagonal so if you play queen takes f5
rook takes g3 and black would have been
right back into the game in the thick of
things that was a mutual blunder maurice
what do you have for us
well it worked out for fabi
despite the fact that he blundered in
that game but not so much for wesley so
in his game against daniel naradicki as
in this situation wesley is cruising
he's got the extra piece with a couple
of pawns dania is looking to somehow
make this pawn work some kind of magic
but here in this position wesley could
have shut it all down
give me the bishop on d6 and then queen
to e4 hey nobody cares about you trading
off and we'll go from here where wesley
will consolidate the position with his
piece and beat back the ferocity the
attempts at least by those pawns what
did he do instead after queen at five he
played bishop e3 a howler that threw
away all his advantage in one move after
rookie eight knight takes d6 rook takes
d6 and all of a sudden the attack is
different you can't play queen e4
there's a rook sitting on that square
and a queen guarding the square as well
that was it his advantage went away he
did sack on his h on a7 and had to go
for the perpet and he blew a golden
chance to be in first place by himself
nice and for a petite combination
we have the following serving arena
crush
against katja the undefeated uh katja
after the movement a7
knight c6 here it comes rook takes d5
very nice play by arena you can't take
the rook the pawn is ready to promote
and after the move rook
a8
this is the important bit the move rook
c5 and or rook d6 both interchangeable
knight takes a7
rook a5 how sweet it is that eternal pin
along the a file
was
arena was able to win a night and her
victory in this game was never in doubt
as she went on to win a game and upset
katya who had previously been
leading the ladies tournament and how
about you maurice anybody sees on
yearbook definitely a brilliant finish
after a couple of blunders actually in
the game between bruzon and jeffrey
zhang and this machine this last move
was a howler rook to b2 looking to
capture the pawn on b5 but jeffrey had a
nasty idea waiting for him here he
played the move rook h6
you can have this thinking pawn why he's
hitting my g-pawn you can have that too
the beautiful retreat queen h8 that's
not a move you see every day a queen
going all the way back in the corner and
even allowing rook takes g5 with check
but after the king's side step it's all
about rook h2 don't try this move queen
g1 thinking you're stopping anybody from
parking in your kitchen with this move
because queen takes is now met by rook
to e2 with check he did try g4 here but
the attack continued king to g3 rook h3
check king back to g2 and then queen to
h4 hitting this rook but more
importantly hitting the g3 square rook
could go to h2 it's all she wrote a
spectacular finish those are not moves
you see every day queen h8 i'm gonna put
that in my book on fantastic retreats
nice and it's the chant the warship
karissa karissa karissa as she played a
superb
game uh in round nine carissa started
this beautiful sequence of moves
beginning with the move d5 bishop takes
d5 knight c3 hitting the queen on a4
hitting the bishop on d5 and after
knight c3 queen dropped back to a6 takes
takes takes hitting the rook on d c8 and
forced to move to d8
all of these moves each and every move
that carissa has made up to this moment
with number one
according to the best chess engine stock
fish and after takes again the very best
move tonight rook takes rook takes
knight takes in this position carissa
played once again the first choice of
the engine queen f4 knight g6 queen c7
she was dominating the position she went
on to win a brilliant game
love it carissa carissa carissa that's
why she's in first christian such a
brilliant game performance all together
by carissa but we i was looking at the
games while you guys were letting the
segment back
so much hit boiling right now we ain't
that game between lenderman and fabiano
caruana fabiano seems to have a golden
opportunity right now to imbalance this
game with the move rook takes i love it
i love it there was this wonderful game
that
magnus carlsen recently won a
magnificent game he sacrificed the
exchange for control over on the king
side i sicilian players
love the sacrifice it's a very very
natural sacrifice you know he is looking
at it right now for sicilian players oh
exactly you've got to do it you have to
do it if you're black and a sicilian and
you get to play rook take c3 the
combination of that move followed by
knight takes e4 it's a dream you set up
a knight on c5 you set up the pawn on f5
wow why there's alex no way
why did he allow this
knight f3 here no way you allow this
sacrifice forcing the pawn to sit on the
c3 square and then the knight can park
itself on c5 that knight f3 has got to
be considered a bad move rook c3 should
be absolutely automatic i remember
yasser you and i did commentary in the
game in a match between
gaspar kasparov and i think it was
junior correct where in the last game
had the chance to sacrifice on c3
innocent and ba imbalance the position
yes and and the kind of sacrifice he
would make in blitz just go instantly
got it let's go and he didn't do it he
actually offered a draw
or did he even do it and call for a draw
he did it
and his and and the computer operator
said sure and he took the draw should
have been no draw rules in that match
that we have here in this tournament but
he did it and afterwards he was drilled
by jeremy schapp this was on espn
drilled by jeremy shap you and i were
co-host of that and jeremy schaaf said
uh excuse me why you know your your
experts are saying that this is a
position you should play and gary said
well he hemmed in hard yeah yeah well
you know the computer sees everything
and
it was a big chance to take to to play
on et cetera et cetera and we were
sitting there like
dude you're getting far off if you have
been playing me or yasasirawan or
anybody human no you would have sacked
on c3 got them from the board and said
i'm gonna beat this clown to death
this is the situation fabi has right now
he shouldn't even be blinking he's just
gonna be going rook c3 and knight takes
e4 and this is exactly the difference
gary was playing a computer he didn't
know what to expect fabiano is playing
alex lenderman with romeo has a great
score he has a great score i was at
dinner with fabiano i hope he's not
going to mind i'm saying this but we
were just discussing players that
haven't lost in this event right and
alex
came about three right and and he said
fabiano wait until tomorrow
okay that's a beat down right there yeah
you got a sack on c3
you have to thank your c3 right
right very nice
and you know
a few days ago
maurice you had actually gone into the
confessional booth
and i have a confession to make as well
and you know when we first started
working together like 25 years ago
almost 30 years ago my gosh
i thought i wasn't going to like you
but
after 25 years of working together
i like to confirm my original opinion
that's my true confession i was
expecting that
come on fabby let's go knight takes e3
what else you got first question
you got to take care of the priorities
we
but i've already admitted on my
confession so i can't like retract right
by the way how's our predictions how are
our predictions doing because i'm losing
track you've been asking us to predict
the results of the game
unfortunately visas god is dead to
rights on that one but our overall
predictions for the tournament well uh
looking much better than he was looking
three rounds ago that's for sure
and you
were really disappointed with yesterday
yeah i've been using youtube
dominguez and caruana in the same boat
right now correct
yeah you're leading yasser with wesley
okay
that's barely it could have been over if
he had won yesterday we might we might
have been saying give it to wesley and
the barn var
don't make more bar var slightly off
participation price yeah it's good to be
in the in the game yeah right
so at least he gets to say he got a
chance to compete against world-class
players now don't this far don't dis
cause when we switch over to you guys
ladies
follow you know great minds think of
life
the chest is stuck out right now and who
you like now in that one so that one
looks uh like
really where in the box
at least one of the commentators is an
outsider right now
we're still in the game all of us we're
still in the game but you got it like my
biggest is if it's far away yeah but i'm
still in the game and i'm okay with that
var for example is not in the game in
the open section why are you doing this
so hard you know what
at the break bar is going to come in
here and and beat you to death
leave our alone all right bart vargas
actually
var could actually win something
christian another hand you might not get
anything
fixed right you're looking unlikely to
get a single picture so is he going
right
so leave him alone
he you know he died
fine but also but what i mean is you
have been asking us to predict the
results of the rounds i don't know if
we've been keeping track of those i do
know i haven't been doing that great
yeah
but i know that maurice has been doing
he had something he's like crazy games
he had some good games yeah of course he
picks the draws all the time so what are
you talking about that's the only time
you won
the only oh and there's the sacrifices
right on time right i don't need for you
to think you got to take that back and
then we're going to see happen smack him
knight takes e4 and fabiano caruana my
pick to win the tournament is playing
like a boss right now he's definitely
not better
let's get it right it's not like black
is suddenly winning but the imbalance
created in the position gives momentum
to black you can never challenge a
knight that will appear on the c5 square
it's important that knight takes e5
right now
is not a move that is hypercritical
knight takes on e5 to continue with
bishop takes e4 it's probably not a move
for a couple of reasons but the most
compelling is just knight takes c3 thank
you very much followed by bishop takes
guarding the knight because when the
knight takes on c3 he's hitting the
queen look at players to kind of glance
over and they say
row something's going on there the heat
is in the direction of fabiano caruana
and this is a golden chance as he went
down the board
interestingly he did something there
that i find fascinating he actually
picked up the knight and moved the rook
to the square you don't normally see
that you normally see rook
capture c3 in one motion right i have i
it's a rare sighting to see a pawn to
see the piece get picked up and the rook
just moved to the square that's quite
interesting because he doesn't do that
normally normally when he's playing
blitz for example you just go spank
and in one motion capture
his own piece first
yeah pick up the rook first and then
capture the knight in in one hand
that for example here you're not going
to see lendermen pick up the rook yeah
and capture back with the pawn let's see
let's see let's see let's see and also
and also the same thing when he plays
knight takes e4 let's see what what
actually transpires we go for oh he did
make a it's so weird watching these
players do this exactly and that's
strange i never see that happen yeah
let's see knight e4 if he picks up that
pawn first i think he's picking the pawn
he's picking the pawn
and yep
what is going on knight takes e4 isn't
that strange you guys don't do that
right no uh i blitz play around more
often
in blitz i'm more often picking up my
piece first and making the move like
i've got a bishop on g7 capturing the
rook on a1 i pick up my bishop and i
capture the rook it's not blitz but this
isn't bliss so this is sort of like your
[ __ ]
you just take the thing
yeah do you do you pick up the piece
first guys in any type any situation no
i'm saying the normal flow from my
normal hand flow is to pick up my piece
first yeah and capture
not picking up the rook first and then
and then
it feels to me like a beginner making
yeah and one of the things i've always
seen like you go to the park you go to
the hustlers and you watch how they
they move and the really really good
players have a very fluid easy motion
and i was shocked
shocked when i first played my first
game against former world champion
vasilis mislove
because the seal he moved the pieces
like
he's like a rock'em sock'em stumbling
you know that move you know like somehow
you know he'd like like knock a few
pieces around and he put it on the board
and he kind of adjust everything it's
like
this guy even know how to play chess
it was so bad
he was he
he was going blind at the time and so he
was just like really struggling and then
i realized later when he would take the
scoresheet and he would lift it up to
his eyes yeah he was going blind but he
was a great player even much later in
his life 60s and 70s he was playing so
he wasn't able to play blitz no
not at all not at all but you're
absolutely right that uh maurice you
were making the point
that alex
and it's very a crucial one the knight
on e4 is on mid-air if knight takes e5
uh the problem
with this
desirable move knight takes e5 with the
idea of capturing the bishop is as
maurice was mentioning knight takes e3
is clean cold refutation the queen is
under
attack the bishop is going to capture
the knight defending this knight
on
c3 so that well you've just blundered uh
uh
two pieces for rook but after knight
takes e4 you are saying
fabby's not winning no he's not winning
but he has exactly what he wants yeah
but
how are you supposed to play this with
with white because i don't really see
reasonable moves so like for for example
you now realize oh man i blew it i
shouldn't have allowed this sacrifice
christian you you've got to bear down
you've got to knuckle down and say i'm i
i i refuse i must
hold the position
what's your ma how do you do that what
are you doing
how do you get counter chances because
exactly the problem with white in this
position is that you have to wait you
have to wait for black to push his pawns
he's going to go f5 move the knight away
and potentially e4 at that point your
knight has to be on f3 raid to jump to
d4 if you try to exchange that knight
with the move knight to d2 the problem
is that knight not being on f3 i'm going
to be able to lock all your pieces if i
move the knight away and play the move
e4 so it's a waiting game right now
you don't think i want to take the pawn
on c3 probably not no probably not i
no no i was thinking that if you did at
least here
i kind of have the impression that well
i i'm kicking up a fuss let's say you
you you you still have this uh love
it's funny you mentioned a moment ago
that the knight on c5 and the night on
v4 do nothing now they actually really
are okay but at least it's and just to
point that out actually for example if
you play a move such as
knight d2 defending the pawn on d
finally okay sure
those knights are perfectly placed to
capture and exchange right now after
knight to c2 there's no way to run with
the rope
because rook to c1 is going to be met by
knight d2 nice not only that i'm going
to pick up your dark square bishop which
is a problem exactly but i'm also going
to pick up the exchange yeah those
knights look lovely in that specific
position um i was thinking the problem
was for me is that okay knight c5
which knight goes to c5 that's a very
good question and i
probably that one i would be
inclined to go with that one and now
knight to c3 potentially
where do you put a queen is the question
i'm not feeling good about
uh my move a c3 c4 that a5 the a4 pawn
is also
maybe now maurice i might be
uh prepping knight e5 by the way that
doesn't win material your h3 pawn will
hang at the end of that so it's a
question of whether or not you want to
give up your light squared bishop
for this trade do we put the bishop on
f5 or do we go f5 let's go f5
f5 f7 f5 okay
guilly if i'm in one
this is this is just which point are you
going to do you've got to get rid of
this knight
can you play knight
d back to d2 i i can't stand these
pieces they've got to go me me either
that but that was what i was trying to
do as white was trade
hence at the very start of this whole
sequence queen b1 by alex lenderman i
was thinking that he might even just go
knight c5 followed by f5 to avoid giving
white any opportunity of trading a minor
but more by the way very importantly
queen e8 wins the a-pawn
one day now
just simply straight up wins the a-pawn
you're gonna lose this pawn then you're
going to see b5 happen and you're going
to start wondering what you're going to
do about this in addition to the f5 idea
the engine says that this is equal-ish
yeah
if
i feel just at sea how to play this
music let me ask the engine
uh since we like this position so much
maybe it's time for that segment
although it's going to be a challenge
for you guys the engine says even the
engine says even when he's going to be
able to do a man a human versus
machinery let's go let's go here let's
do a human versus machine because we
love
the humans i'm with you love this
position with black
let's see if you can
increase the advantage that's all i'm
going to ask right increase the
advantage right now the engine's staying
equal if you could increase the
advantage prove the engine wrong that's
all you need you don't need to forget a
winning position or anything i just
can't crazy event i just want to keep
you balanced okay i'm telling you with
the challenge
increase the advantage
you can play all right black
white can start with the move rook to
three not a move at all that is nobody's
liking this one but that's it alex is
not gonna play that much i mean if he
plays it wow okay f7 f5 feels like has
to be played or knight c5 one of the two
which knight yeah i would put the knight
on a6 in that case but i like f5 should
we go with knight c5 first
it does put a lot of pressure on that a4
pawn and i think it's important to get
there fast
[Music]
let the rooks do on a3 if he plays c4 we
could put tonight on b4 but you know
what we're threatening with the move
knight c5 what do we threat bishop takes
a4
so if you go knight to d2 for example
then i can play bishop takes a4 you're a
dangerous man a danger i'm attracted to
that yes okay uh we
the captain got overridden by his first
mate i'm surprised i'm surprised it
usually wimps out
okay come on now it's time to defend the
knight let's go f5 okay come on all
right f5 right now knight to d2 this is
what this was what we were always
fearful of is that the knight would
eventually problem and now we're going
to have to trade we have to trade up
we cannot leave it there no we got a
trade which is take it well we could go
back hold on hold on hold on maybe then
bishop takes
c65 and then knight c4 and then we can
go e4
uh i wish i had my pawn on b no but then
looks like d1 and that d-pawn looks a
bit threatening we're giving him counter
play yeah i think so i don't want to
allow him to take on c5 so you want to
take on d let's take on d2 yeah oh man
but i feel like we're we're losing our
advantage when we do this again we're
playing knight takes d2
okay best move queen takes on d2 okay
now this is the big pause because
as the champion
president of the pawn grubbers
pawn uh grubbers uh
every fiber of my being wants to capture
that pawn on a4
i mean i don't i can play b6 i can wimp
out i could even play e4 but i want to
take that pawn or queen c7
i was inclined towards queen c7 but
let's calculate so you take on a4
he's gonna play rook a1 we play b5 he's
going to play c4 we get to play e4
tickling the rook on a1 he's going to
have to move his rook he doesn't
what he can take on b5 well then we take
a rule and then take the knight
well we win back our exchange and that's
something the pawn on
a5 and that pawn is going to b6
what have we lost in in that whole
sequence it's equal the position is
equal but this one is going to be six
okay then you're thinking that we have
to defend the knight then i just have to
slow play with queen c7 okay queen c7
i'm still not i'm not grooving
to what we've done i think we may have
uh fallen were we supposed to take that
pawn i was uh the right move was was
supposed to be
b6
bishop c5 now queen c5 265 rook to b3
okay and live with this can't we live
with this
just a second how are we doing maurice
uh you're maintaining the balance we're
maintaining maintaining the balance but
it's no longer
i think you would i think we would all
agree that this is not i was exciting
for black no i okay after rook a3 let's
just try this one by the way okay
it looks very unnatural wait a minute we
got to stop we're going to stop there we
will analyze now but i'm going to say
you guys maintain the balance
and that should let's call that last uh
exchange a draw we've never had that
between humans okay okay
let's call it a draw you guys maintain
the balance you've proved that you have
compensation
and you can
without much thinking time for your side
maintain the balance at least so that it
we're gonna call that the end of the
match i'm not happy with that you're not
happy i'm happy i'm okay
it's okay
the referee is
a draw
all right let's fail let's now back up
and analyze it okay since you're no
longer under pressure
and lenderman
by the way and he played queen c2 so
finding engine moves
not easy this is why fabi is going into
this line because he knows most like 4k
3 don't come to your brain easily no
let's be real that's not the kind of
move you want to play so it's even more
challenging to play this with the white
pieces queen c2 on the board
and this still not a bad move as the
engine says you should now play knight a
to c5 and guess what the next best move
rook a3 once again putting this rook on
the a3 square
interesting defense by the engine to put
the rook on a3
what do you guys think about this
position again b6 very solid play
by black sooner or later you feel the f5
steam though
coming behind your neck like this is
going to happen at some point right so
it's not a kind of position clearly it's
not the kind of position where black
just wins no no or black just pressure
is white and it's that easy it's going
to be one of those that white
will try to defend and black will look
for the opportunities and then hope that
white doesn't find the most accurate
moves and suddenly he steals the
initiative exactly but it's his best
chance go for it with the sacrifice and
see what happens and can the world
number two player who's by the way
slipped a lot of rating points
and on the next official list if he
stays here will be number three in the
world can he
win this game get the trend his way
get some rating points back and
potentially be tied for first after this
round where we will have white in the
last round
nobody in this tournament wants to see
him typhoon first with one round to go
exactly by the way i want to turn to our
attention i mean always in the shadows
ray robson in the shadows of our legends
of fabi wesley lanier he has played
bishop f4 inviting
john burke to a part of me he played
knight f5 inviting john burke to capture
this this was a glorion
okay with knight a5 and c5 and knight c4
queens
knight
to c4 and john is saying hey man i'm a
pawn up do your worst ray said thank you
for that opportunity let me do my worst
bang
bishop takes h6 john says well wait a
minute i can't allow bishop takes g7 and
queen g5 i'm going to take that bishop
knight takes and we are up to date with
the players is this going to go into our
brilliancies
or blunders well let's start calculating
yasser
well first of all that bishop on c2 is
lurking right the bishop on c2 is
lurking so don't even think about
grabbing the king and putting it on h7
your only choice is to play bishop takes
h6 which he did or king h8 i thought
king h8 was
maybe the better move he's already taken
the queen makes a very striking
appearance on the h6 square ice
fortunately for he won't have to worry
about a rover
but at the moment he's looking at knight
f5 i assume his plan i thought it is
knight h7
you think knight h i thought knight a7
is almost forced for resigns with knight
h7 after e5 i was about to say e5 then
you can start crying no don't don't
think about allowing this move e5 but
here's what i was thinking uh was john's
defensive idea i don't know if it's
going to work i remember i think it was
wesley so just
killing
um
uh
got to kamsky and by the way
he's on the board yeah i was thinking
he's he's
he's planning to get out of the way
to drop his knight back to cover the g7
square and to
uh put his rook on g6 and put his work
on jesus that's what raised everything
okay so here we are
and again is this a brilliancy by rey
or has it been blunderful so it seems
like knight f5 only feels automatic
right okay knight of a
pardon me knight f8
now we're going to put the
i'm going to get this right knight e8
protecting g7 attacking the queen how do
you continue
so hard win by rey
gets one right back there's only one
pawn only one bomb because we already
lost one on p2
so
if i go queen to g5 are you going to
go 97 oh sorry rook to g67
now you're getting added
your eye is faster than the brain queen
g5 check uh the immediate rook g6 as you
were about to say does allow knight e7
check and i get to take the rook so no
against the moon you want to keep your
peace i'm i'm greedy i will step aside
or greedy man all right so how can i
continue my attack now and you know that
ray has something in mind he definitely
has
something in mind so if i go queen on
the h file aren't you forced to go back
to g8
uh
h4 i just want to keep some control over
dark squares queen the h4
i don't think it makes too much of a
difference but i want to keep control on
the dark squares
well that's actually a very nice thing
to have in mind because if you can do
this then you're getting your queen you
remember your queen started at h6
so you get your queen out of danger
with tempo
and i can't play the or can i play the
desired rook g6 it's not gonna look
pretty but you can play that move yes
and queen to ha rook to g8 queen to h6
knight to g7 i'm in a very awkward pin
but very awkward for the moment i'm a
piece up and you you oh so let's dream i
know the rook 33 is not possible that's
a problem yeah you're dreaming of a
rover all right let's do it slowly
let's do it slowly well i'm not that
slow i'm gonna play rook to e6 and kick
the queen and don't don't forget
things are lurking john burke
is still in this but i like what you
said there
about your whole queen g5 queen h4
approach
uh but is it a winning advantage oh
don't no i don't think it's winning no
no no no no no we may have to turn to
maurice on this one and bale is out of
our dilemmas here because
um
it's not an enterprising play by ray
definitely not winning and he and all he
has are queen and knight
and black's attacking
right but apparently compensation
bishop b3 for example is one move to try
to get rid of that knight and then try
to use your rooks on the open files but
it's far from clear it's far from clear
the engine's saying uh the less than a
pawn advantage to black
clearly white has compensation we can
see it's scary around that king but
there's a very specific defense with 98
and shifting the black king out of the
way so ray can look all he wants to he's
not gonna find a win at the end of that
and he's gonna have to figure out where
we're gonna just be playing chess
that's
a committal thing to have to realize
right a huge realization like i'm not
winning
but how do i play what what do you do to
increase
some initiative some some kind of play
if you're white well exactly that i i
didn't consider eliminating the knight
with bishop to b3 and getting a rover
going i was thinking more about bringing
the rook into play we'll keep an eye on
that but you had another game uh set up
that you wanted to talk about maurice
yes this game with carissa and i as i
said when you're not really sure about
things in a position
that's when carissa starts to play a
little bit worse and here we see she
just played the move g5 after knight f6
her opponent did play d5 said i'm going
to take the space and we can work it
from here e5 the natural response knight
to h2 in a position like this one
you've got to be careful where you put
your pieces and she decided to play
knight to h5 right at this moment
looking for a potential f5 break
yourself yeah rook f2 e1
oh yes rook after e1 played in the
position she's always by the way you got
to watch out for a bishop e2 kind of
shot
and here after rook after e1 she played
the move g5 and we can see what her plan
is she wants to put a knight on f4
potentially put the other knight on g6
white will aim for the square
potentially with knight back at night
here but there's a knight waiting
there's also the other night that can go
here so you can play night night one
night and then finally you're able to
see this square for yourself it's still
one of those turgid positional battles
going on but certainly if you're black
you know you're you're kind of
playing with a little bit of gambling uh
in mind because you have weakened some
squares
we'll see can naji find herself as we
see the standings this matters is so
much
in this position and
if she wins carissa is on her way to the
championship without any question about
it but she's got her hands full in this
position nazi can certainly challenge
her as she's conceded some light squares
on the square i see the knight to e2
and potentially something landing on g3
and f5 becomes a factor
the fact that you gave white something
very easy to do something very clear
is what
you didn't want to have
you don't want to give that to white
where you have just a crystal clear plan
in mind and this one i would say is what
has just happened with that move g5 yeah
i really love the move knight c3 e2 i
think the knight on h2 i'm not happy
about it but i think it has work that it
can do over on that side of the board
whether it be knight g4 and again
rerouting to
g3 but knight c3 to e2 the knight on c3
is not working in my opinion knight c3
to e2 knight g3
challenging the knight on h5 prepping a
knight on f5 trade double the pawns i'm
kind of happy
with perhaps we can actually look on
your board yes sir because i think this
is a perfect example of those type of
positions where you have to think and
ask the question which one of my pieces
is not playing how can i improve it this
is the perfect example of that that
knight on c3 doesn't make a good
impression no all of the
desired
forward squares b5 and d5 has already
occupied it uh and b5 is covered so i do
and you don't have a lot of options i
mean the bishop c4 is not great either
but you will be able to drop it to e2
maybe on f1 to defend the king's side at
some point the knight on c3 has to be
rerouted and i do like the idea of this
move knight to e2 and you were
mentioning that knight on h2 doesn't
make a clear impression right now but
for example when we see the move knight
to f4
and potentially black go h5 h4 try to
relocate the knight from g3 then that g4
square becomes available exactly and i
like that a lot exactly i was by the way
i'm not sure if carissa will want to
castle kingside because that attack is
not going to open up that easily
i really i'm just kind of putting some
uh position
moving pieces kind of getting a zen at
the position bishop comes back to f1
prepping c2 c4 prepping for knight g4
knight f5 and g3
this is going to be
very intriguing to watch it unfold and
maurice back over to you this is my kind
of game
to watch some moves in this position
that are just high
level moves by black on every single
turn katarina namsova
desperate now after she lost the lead
lost the game potentially just watching
even a chance on the podium slip away as
begin has played some marvelous moves
after knight c5 rook f to d1 bishop e6
queen d a rook f bishop takes nbc now
watch this this is styling and profiling
the next few moves white attacks the
bishop and the pawn on c6
the bishop drops back a retreating move
it looks passive you see the passive
moves being made here bishop to a3
follows behind it with a pin on the
knight this bishop drops back now it's
defended
nicely rook to d2 looking to double
along the file and get some pressure and
now the final stylish move bishop back
to e8 it looks like black has been on
the defensive being pushed back pushed
back but all of a sudden it's black who
is way better thanks to all these moves
one threat in the position is 94
unleashing the attack on this bishop
we've got the pin on this line as well
and black has played these these moves
that look
like they're defensive but in fact they
are high class retreating moves that
consolidates her position and now
prepares for her to break out and go
after white engines love this position
and say every single move was perfect
that black just played and it's white
who's struggling right now and she's
about to double rooks
but i believe this move is a mistake
which allows the move knight to a4
to be played knight that's a nice shot
knight to a4 forcing you to now trade
you have to take here if you take on f8
knight c3 first is coming at you so you
have to trade this off give the two
bishops up and you don't have an obvious
move here as you're going to be down a
full pawn
they may be doubled but
one one is passed two of them actually
both passed but your knight is going to
try to need to control these these pawns
and the the position liquidates down
into advantage black two bishops extra
pawn even if it weren't extra there's
one that's there that's passed and white
is going to struggle to stay in this
game as begum is playing great has she
won two in a row
in a row two in a row this could be her
third in a row she's come back quite
nicely in this event and she will put
herself in at least clear third
possibly even second if irina only draws
and she'll be tied for a second but if
she if arena falters then she'll be in
clear second meantime we got that big
game between carissa to see if she has a
chance because if carissa loses and
begin wins she's only half a point out
of first and there's a mathematical
chance there for her to tie
or even overtake carissa if carissa
collapses and she'll find herself in the
championship circle and carissa is
playing katarina in the last round so
that's not an easy matchup either no
absolutely first of all i just want to
say
thank you maurice that was a really
remarkable conception
bishop f8 bishop e8 now comes knight a4
you thought i was on the back foot no no
crouching tiger hitting dragon very very
nice just wanted to jump very quickly to
the game of arena so important to our
standings when we left it
uh well the panel felt like uh
um italia was for choice she had the
nice meroxie vine set up this bishop
made a kind of a woeful impression on
the e6 square i was agitating for knight
d5 i like those central knights that are
so well protected
and
also maybe
threatening knight f4
talia's approach was a bit more direct
she played f4 a4 and it was sort of like
the cleaners came in and just hosed down
the pieces as we got here now this is a
very important moment i don't like
irina's decision to capture with a
knight it's it's okay nothing's wrong
with it and
but she needs a win she needs a win and
she needs an imbalance
win this position i think she would have
been better off capturing with the
knight and kind of playing a position of
knight versus bishop in this specific
uh type of sequence we often see the
knight
like we see in the fabiano's game trying
to reposition itself to c5
it's not going to be an easy win
but it allows certainly yeah that we you
need something you can't just trade
everything down she did however
and this is irina's wrote ahead
christian absolutely she's playing today
with the black pieces against talia
cervantes and tomorrow she has white
against tatev abrahamian
rivalry between those two uh but after
knight d5 she captured with the knight
we've now reached this position after a3
b6 we can see that what arena's plan is
once again she wants to post up on c5 so
that after any rook is traded she will
then recapture with the b-pawn and
eyeball the open up the
i like talia's move by the way you make
a quick v-line into the sun the king and
the ending is a very very powerful piece
and we've caught up to the players as we
get ready for a quick break we will go
on a quick break as we are approaching
the time travel situation and we will
see you guys on the other side
[Music]
founded in 1839 the university of
missouri is steeped in tradition the
recently founded mizzou chess program is
a partnership between the university of
missouri and the st louis chess club
collegiate jess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of excellence
mizzou has always strived for the best
mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institutions
ethos of respect responsibility
discovery and excellence to the
chessboard
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
so
[Music]
[Music]
high
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to our continuous
coverage of round number 10 here at the
us chess championships the games are
hitting up what is the action yasser
well the action is with our leaders
christian and uh after let's just jump
to the game of alex lenderman versus
fabiano a wonderful exchange sacrifice
bobby's got a knight in a pawn for a
rook and when we left it we left it just
about these queen c2 parts knight came
back to d2
queen c7 rook a3 that was that very
difficult
the chess laid the move
he spotted that move that he needed to
defend his two weaknesses the pawns on
a4 and c3 thabbe said you go ahead and
defend all you like i'm going to make an
expansion on the king side i'll either
play for f5 f4 or e5 e4 by the way one
thing that i really like about fabiano's
play right now
is and i don't know the evaluation of
the engine is that he's keeping pieces
on the board he's not changing anything
he did not exchange knight on d2 keep
the pieces on the board keep the tension
on the board and wait for the time
trouble situation when your opponent
potentially could make a mistake exactly
i agree with you i like his patient
approach f4
rook e8 takes on
e5
uh what does marie say about trades that
is fantastic or fabulous or forget about
it forgettable we have this bishop
lurking on the e5 square hitting the
pawn on g3
alex had to back up
and look at this talk about thematic
brakes
wow
i love what fabi has gotten
going and after rook a
i'm thinking a f whoa
knight could drop into d3
ooh
some juicy knight to d3 then the other
knight comes to c5 everything there is a
beautiful synergy between black's pieces
i feel like
nevertheless he cannot blink he needs to
do something fast well i'm thinking a5
that's kind of the late well that's a
lazy man's little decision i cannot uh
cotton that knight coming to d3 i better
play bishop f1 but now if we exchange
those your d5 pawn is going to be a
weakness and i'm not even convinced that
i have to take on b1 first okay okay
that's fine let's take on f1 yes rook
takes that takes f4 and now let's put
some pressure on that d5 pawn queen to
b7 or queen to d7 or b7 boy 7 okay
so uh
you're gonna jump i'm gonna jump around
let's jump i'm gonna jump around not
sure where well i would say i was at
first i was afraid of night before and
hitting my queen but my queen can keep
the d3 square so how do we see
how beautiful the rook on a3 and why it
was so important as it does cover a lot
of squares you mean it's it's a nice
rook but i still like black queen to b2
wow nice just drop i want to exchange
the queens now because i have another
weapon that pawn on a4
that's going to go down the board
very quickly
yes i understand you're complaining if
you go to a2 i caged the rook with a
move a3 and this doesn't look good not a
happy camera you might be able to
sacrifice an exchange somehow but i have
knight before coming very quickly i
don't know yes this is on the edge for
white i think the momentum is definitely
in fabie's favor i just don't know if
it's going to be enough for a win
i think it's advantage fabby but we'll
see and maurice i got to ask you how is
the tournament leader carissa yipp
handing the handling the pressure at the
ultimate round well her position looks
dubious we didn't like the opening
choice for sure but she's doing what she
does putting pressure on her opponents
by direct play by aggressive play
forcing them to burn time on the clock
and that's exactly what's happening in
your game with naji [ __ ] right now as
you look at that huge time advantage
almost 30 minutes
15 minutes and change on the clock for
naji in a position where they've only
played 21 moves she's got 19 moves to go
and karissa has made it very clear i've
lined my pieces up against you and i'm
coming after your king and i might
sacrifice in order to achieve that aim
and now she has to calculate it she
can't just intuitively say well it'll
all work out i'll just let her sack for
a couple of pawns and open up my king we
know how the youngster thinks that's
like waving a red flag
in front of a bull take a look at the
game the way it went g3 in this position
stopping anything from going to f4 good
idea knight g6 these knights are
fighting over a square that's well
protected so nothing happening there
queen d1 hitting the knight chasing it
back bishop f1 guarding this entire side
and after bishop c8 a5 looking to open
up this side b5 played quickly bishop to
g2 bishop d7 all played quickly by the
way knight f1 queen c8 king to h2 and h5
on the board now you don't want to take
this pawn and let this happen you know
what's coming the opening of the well
the sacrifice is what's coming you do
this and then you can just expect her to
sack expect her to capture your bishop
is left so this square is a problem you
can't go to h1 and if you go to g1 well
here it comes there's more and more
action for black that's what she wants
she wants aggression in this position
please take something now you want to
know what the engine's top move is
facing off with the h4 threat g4 where
you can always play h4 you know what it
is
knight a2
move on the complete other side of the
board and say black do your worst i
don't believe you i don't think this is
going to work well
humans will panic almost after this move
looking to open up the file you shut it
down giving this
to black
just just starts to feel like you're in
danger like maybe this is a problem but
the engine says we don't believe
anything you're doing you can keep going
the bishop is rock solid guarding here
you cannot break through easily it's two
pawns
for the piece but you're just lost your
attack is going nowhere and it's going
to be beaten back these things will
eventually start to hang knights hanging
right now paul will potentially hang
near term
this one is amazing defense shows that
the sacrifice does not work which means
that naji in this original position has
to calculate all that and say
i'm good there i don't believe you i
think i can make that work but she has
the choice of taking on g5 at the moment
which is not actually good for her
or playing knight a2
i got to tell you whoever you are i
don't care how good you are maybe if
you're petrossian and karpov and the
great defenders and you see that a
completely unfortunately
different approach she
refused to sit there and play a move
like f4 none of us believe that that is
not the legal movement no that is not
instantly bad and in fact the engines
are screaming that black is now winning
after this move we're not surprised by
that that decision could give carissa
the championship how can you open up the
game in black's favor that is a horrible
move f4
it's simply unacceptable as a move i
don't even get it the point is you're
giving away two pawns like you're giving
away a pawn
for what
for nothing this is
foreign this is panic absolute panic see
this is what carissa believes in her
heart and soul
i pressure them
they crack
and she's done it time and time again
and this one is a high level blunder i
mean the worst or the worst karissa's
like trying to
get her eyes clear to see a move like f4
or land on the board just because the
white
the black king is still in the middle
trying to break open the position with
this this is a horrible move don't
forget black and castle still it's still
legal so
so if need be i'm just saying if it's
bail time right black can run but black
doesn't need to no okay but why because
it's pure panic i can't believe we even
saw it and by the way black has five
pieces directly trained at the white
king exactly sorry five no no no no no
one queen on c8 bishop on d7 knight on
f6 knight on g6 rook on h8
count the pawns too yeah i just said the
pieces the pieces i i i'm just saying
the pawns will be in the in the bishop
on g7
after the movie i see all of that but
there are five that are directly trained
the rest are also waiting okay even the
rook on a8 is thinking is going to join
the party at some point gentlemen this
is just disastrous
funny enough i think and exactly at this
moment we might have different
approaches
uh to carissa's position i think f4 is
it howler a terrible terrible blunder uh
but my approach to the position when i
see that i'm trying to open up the king
side i'm thinking h5
four
i want to open up the rook on the h file
by the way
i think that's exactly what nazi wants
h4 h4 because then she can close things
up with f5 is their move she's looking
for you're saying she really wants to
play the move f5 okay let let's look at
this h4 by the way i'm not saying that
i'm not getting it
but it looks much better now with the
diagonal closed knight takes
knight f4
and you think that uh she's going to
keep the position closed
rook h-fork
not why i i feel it's still a game if
you take on f4 i feel it's just simply
not a game okay good point good point i
really don't see how you can play this
movie before and not immediately be
punished
just be super happy that you're even in
this actually now i take it back because
i see i do have a way of opening up the
kingdom if you want also if you want to
there's some i'm not sure if i'm ready
to do that it's totally ready knight g4
is coming yeah and uh i'm just thinking
that somewhere here maybe just 95 and 99
i mean if you asked if you totally see
for for me it was david bronstein
ethan geller they played the king's
indian like nobody's business and
they're sacrificing a minor in peace a
knight for two beautiful pawns the rook
there's a knight on c3 the rook on a1
you're telling me your material down
uh-uh you have to show me something
please yeah
take the pawn twice on f4
right with the knight or with the pawn
the pawn of course okay what we got yeah
and i'm i mean now play bishop and i'll
play bishop d4 bishop to d4 yeah i did
that too oops that's yeah
i just i'm just very curious yeah if she
plays uh a random move knight h4 is it
king f8 i'm going to play the most rent
sure
what's attractive what's the point
i have no idea there is no point i have
no i i think f4 was a stone cold blind
frightened panic
panic mode absolutely that's what
happened she's down there last 12
minutes 30 minutes right now after the
increment it's crazy she's feeling the
pressure yeah there's a lot of pieces
coming towards her that was my thought
when she was reaching first pressure
just made her blow it remember we said
she had to stay cool carmen night day
two right
like her brain said no no i'm not going
for it she sucked she saw her opponent
sacrificing right and she didn't want to
calculate what would happen as a result
of the sacrifice to make sure she was
okay it's easy for us to talk sitting
here
admittedly right but we also agree that
you got to look at it and once you look
at it you go is it really working
she saw a sack for two pawns was
inevitable and she said i don't want to
be that person i want to be the person
that takes over the attack from carissa
the problem is she's giving attack even
more to carissa by opening lines that
carissa was struggling to open and
needed a p sack to do it now she doesn't
even need a p sack the game just plays
itself right when
when maggie was reaching for her f1 i
genuinely thought she was going to play
f3
with the idea of you know locking up and
in case in case
of g4 now the bishop and queen are kind
of stunted a little bit so that after
takes takes h4 again this knight on f1
is doing really good defensive yeoman
duties and that's what i thought it was
first oh maybe the new f3 is not so bad
we didn't really look at it she went
forward
oh my goodness so we are in this
situation and it just feels to us like
carissa is just a few steps away from
claiming her very very first u.s women's
championship title and it definitely
seems like she will be claiming it
because irena crush is not winning that
end game right now uh oh and if irena
doesn't win and carissa wins done we
have a champion with four
champions former champions going under
on her belt saying oh look at the people
i beat to get the title and she's
already defeated three of them this move
is absolutely stunning we cannot believe
it was played and carissa
herself let me think are you kidding
just opening up lines i couldn't have
dreamt of a move like this to be played
as we come to the current situation
carissa hasn't moved she's still
probably stunned wait wait wait wait
wait a minute i
i'm supposed to school you with a move
like this one it just looks illogical in
all respects the only thing that might
spook carissa is her king sitting on e8
just to make sure that there are no
tactics against her king that's the only
thing that might spook her a little bit
and that's what i think naji is hoping
to somehow justify but we don't believe
it right we just don't believe it can be
real and
the black pieces
are are trained far more so at the white
king which will be so much more exposed
after the double capture on f4 right
horrendous move and she took it on f4
she's going to open up that
b8 h2 diagonal that bishop is going to
land on e5 tonight coming to g4
unbelievable and she said confidently
just took twice this game over and said
show me show me what you got
right
incredible we're seeing the potential
coronation
of the next generation of champions here
if carissa wins her confidence level
will be very high
she will have literally smashed her way
to the championships afterwards
after losing to begin she's been on a
tear and the games have not been close
no it hadn't been like oh there was
maneuvers they got to an end game and
she had to win some technical no it's
been the the flintstones bam bam like
come here i'm just hitting you over the
head every single game has been like
that and this one is looking like it as
well as her opponent panicked and might
give her
i might call it the bingo well five in a
row you got the olympic rings for the
olympic rings you lose five you win five
bingo you get five in a row and bingo
that's right
bingo right you get five in a row that's
how you win at bingo so she could she
could get a bingo right now with five in
a row
if she wins this one
and it's looking like she won't give
this up this looks great for her and by
the way this is all you need to see naji
is pausing in a position where simple
double captures has occurred well she
displayed that f4 which she expected her
opponent exactly you must have something
after double captures like what were you
thinking she was going to do when she
took your two pawns didn't you have a
move planned here exactly
all right i mean you said that well
irina's not winning the ending and i
will
agree with you
except i would also say that
uh she's got an ending
where she's got the she's playing for
slightly better side it's not much let's
look at it actually okay so
i think talia just made a really good
move she said brooke to c4 essentially
what that move suggests to my eyes is
she wants to play rook on the first rank
to c3 and then rook over to b4 and then
that means that whole side's been
completely neutralized forever and ever
you can play the move bishop b5 and
that's kind of where the bishop
starts from and now
her pre i wanted to say arena's previous
move
and now after rook c4 you could go back
to d7 or e8 and and you can try to go
rook to c8 now i think that's a good
does white have a plan in this position
do you want to go h3 g4 i think the most
important thing is actually two getting
the move g2 g3 and if i were in
white shoes i would be looking to trade
the light square bishops
so you're not looking to take any
unnecessary risks and i never and this
is i really want to emphasize this i'm
never interested in playing rook takes
e5 because i think that when i
that b6 pawn
no it is it it it's not fearsome
but when you take on c5 and you open up
half open up the b file uh
what is it
bangkok gambit players they suddenly go
oh i know this structure finally i've
got something to play for but the
problem is arena is running out of focus
this one very close to equality what's
happening in the latest game between the
ladies nemtsova and but maurice wants to
jump in sorry
you're talking about in a second but
something huge going on wesley so and
sam savion two of the leaders the
co-leaders are repeating oh and we may
see a full-scale repetition leading to a
draw if they draw
then that means that fabiano caruana
suddenly has his destiny in his own
hands as a victory over the final
co-leader alexander lindemann would
leapfrog him into a tie for first
miraculously after playing one of the
horrible tournaments we've ever seen him
play one of the most horrible he
sitting in five could actually jump to
six
joining wesley and sam if they draw
relegating lenderman back into a tie for
fourth at at best right
and no one else could be ahead of him
and he'll have white going into the last
round it would be an amazing result for
him if he could pull off the victory
here something we could not have
imagined from him when he was playing so
badly earlier in the tournament suddenly
he could be at least in a tie and then
whatever happens in the last round he
would look at a playoffs and i don't
think anybody wants to see fabiano
surging in this event so he's pretty
confident right now let's look look at
the board position he did not play a4 he
played knight to d3 i like it which hits
which now forces some great calculation
by the way
by his opponent if rook takes on a5
knight takes f2
rook takes on b5 there is this move
waiting queen to a7
now if you're black you've got to pay
attention to this move because your king
is suddenly caught in a little bit of a
funny situation by the way this pawn on
g3 as we see this game has ended in a
draw
that's over a huge result for the
tournament no question about it and
those players will go rest and wait
for the result of this game that we're
looking at right now
queen over to a7 and now but check out
the next move because your king is is in
a very strange situation world of hurt
the move knight f1 is the engine move
whoa like insanity i'm going to go back
let me turn it on since i'm not going to
pretend i know what's happening if king
to h2 f4 just wins like
the dark squares attack is way too
strong
and
what where if king over 2f1 then there's
this move knight takes and if bishop
takes queen e3
what kind of variation is this are you
kidding me bishop takes his threat and
queen takes his threat if you give up
this knight on a6 bishop takes and it's
all she wrote there's an e3 attack
coming f2 attack coming you honestly wow
you could easily fall for this by the
way if you are white something like this
could happen after a seven that is
2 800 type chess we're in right now the
only defense that we found so far knight
to f1 allowing you to get away with any
disco you want this knight has six moves
okay that one's out but that one's one
that's another that's that's one that
this knight can go a bunch of squares
you have to calculate knight f1 as your
defense
good luck
good luck by the way even here the game
is still sharp after knight f1 there is
a knight e4 sighting and again this f4
problem is real you you go into h2 you
will have to give this up but you do get
counter play on the other side
this is crazy talk fabiano caruana has
found a way to enliven the game with
knight to d3 putting his opponent
into the think tank and the time says 20
minutes on the clock to survive this
attack 16 moves if lenderman gets out of
this i say give him the title because
this is all star defense necessary in
order to survive this game by the way no
all-star defense for uh naji because she
after the double capture on f4 followed
up with a second howler i really dislike
this move e5 this was her calculation
this was her calculations she's trying
to make hay of the fact that black's
king is in the center but in fact
without the rook
white has nothing there's no nothing
attacking the black king other than the
rook on e1
boom
knight to chief check why not on you
hghg king g1
thank you i'll take that one as well by
the way i was looking more at the
castle
i was looking more in this direction
than the other direction we were talking
about what number of pieces are
attacking i was counting the bishop as
well on g7 she did take the third pawn
with takes bishop c5 queen
that queen is coming and it's coming
fast on h4
bad news for white right now nazi
pakistan in a world of trouble
absolutely no that that whole
sequence by white just
opened up everything for black's pieces
and now the king is suffering we have
special guests we do have a special
guest ashrita eswaran is with maurice we
see one former champion going down here
ashrita was able to take down another
former champ and we weren't paying too
much attention to your game as aretha as
there's other games that were afoot but
now that i had a chance to look at it
wow
diamonds in my eyeballs yasser go to
move 18 on your board and let us enjoy
the evisceration that ashrita put on
well move 18 is the move bishop e7 after
rook b3 bishop e7 right here and as rita
what an attack you got the position was
fairly nondescript but suddenly she just
gave you some chances with this move f5
um yeah i was actually surprised by her
opening choice with the c-takes d4 here
in the steinitz variation i just thought
i think
i was actually in my preparation till
queen h4 check and then i couldn't
really remember it but i think after
bishop f2 it felt easy for me to play
especially with her king in the middle
of the board
um
and after queen d8 castle i thought you
know she queens i thought maybe rook c8
instead of queen seed but she started i
think here she spent like 40 minutes on
the clock
um and so i felt like she thought it was
an uncomfortable position for her and so
after queen c8 rook b3 bishop e7 i
thought i had to go for this f5 move
just go for the attack sure
and i didn't really see like i thought
her queen c4 was good and then i wasn't
entirely sure if rookie one was correct
or not but i thought rookie one and if
she castles
f6
g takes f6 and queen h6 and then i'm
threatening my d5 and rogue g3 and i
think
she's in trouble there
nasty no question about that that looks
like a really nice you're all set up
with the rover so
she played bishop c6 to avoid castling
the engine says that that's a blunder
bishop b4 was best and now here you come
yeah i thought uh when she played bishop
c6 and back to d7 she allowed me to
regroup my pieces a little bit and
knight d4
and rook c8 and then i thought you know
maybe she's threatening bishop b4 here
and so i was like just stop everything
with a3 um
and then no counter chances in here e6
fe 6 knight e6 i saw this like a couple
moves ahead she took on e6 rookie 6 and
king f7 and here i think rookie six
rookie seven is just winning king e7
queen g5
i thought party i thought her best move
was king d6 instead of king e6
because if i go king d6 and then if i
try like queen g7 with the idea queen f6
and rex c3 i thought i saw she had queen
b3 here
c takes b oh
that's a tricky one easy to miss
and so after king d6 but the engine zoo
gave queen h6 check after queen takes b3
guarding the c1 square nice intermezzo
oh
yeah and i saw this afternoon i was like
okay you know queen g5 is winning and
then but she played king e6 instantly
which surprised me which just allowed
rookie 3
king d6 queenie 7 and rookie 6.
and she's getting mated i believe
yes
wow
convincing i'll beat them i was like
very absolutely beat down
ashrita you are doing quite well in this
event but a hiccup here and there
kind of dampened your opportunities how
are you feeling about the tournament
after this round i'm really glad i could
get a win especially like this um i had
a rough three days i'd say i think two
games i should have lost that i lost and
then one game that you know i was losing
and then almost had a draw it had five
moves till then that was very painful
but chess is hard so chess is hard but
this one is one to smile about beating a
former champ in this style we'll let you
rest for the last round thank you
well done very very nice and again we're
looking at chris's position and saying
everything's going yes sir it is indeed
and that one seems to be going karissa's
way she's going to finish she's going to
get the title but
fabiano caruana is in the game in this
championship because alex lederman
flinched
he did not go for the variation that
maurice was pointing out that critical
variation after queen to a7 knight to f1
he played a different move how do we
feel about this move queen to b1 and
knight a b4 is on the board
wow
queen bee one attacking the baby is that
how you play chess you just like give up
your well in this case the whole point
is he wants to play knight takes after
two king takes f2 as losing for a host
of reasons but knight takes f2 queen
takes b5 b5
keeps i don't know something going
sometimes a4
right so you first play knight b4 now
you want to take the knight then you've
opened up the bishop so that the bishop
can land on d4 it's all about the king
side attack forget about what's going on
on the queen side you've got two rooks
over there who's defending the king
knight f2 is fabi's killing to
understand this position you need two
hours
later one has 17 minutes on the clock
not good not good this is not looking
good for him no the challenge is
is too rough here this is actually one
of the more beautiful
is that the checkmate that that looks
like
uh well you cannot go to e3 yeah no for
for for oh oh oh oh oh
come up come up come up come on
let's go
yeah yeah no i like i like g5 i like g5
stop it everybody let's do it with tempo
so this is where the whole tournament
hall comes even the arbiters by the way
even the arbiters come home
yes please please since i want to throw
in my two cents yeah uh there you even
have the retreating bishop to e5
check okay so pick up the rook
while we're at it
let's just take the just
yeah
yeah yeah yeah i've got to go back again
all right now you're being cruel
cruel is nice nah cruel is good
krill
now on the board
okay we're about to see
well let's take a look
okay
let let's go through
how we want to play pieces
hanging the c3 pawn looks delish hitting
the knight on d2 and preparing to take a
rook on a1 if needed and preparing to
take a bishop on f2 as needed they're so
there's just gorgeous pawn to eliminate
remember the rook sacked on exchange on
that square many moves ago
and that pawn was was holding everything
together
you take out the linchpin of white's
defense and suddenly what is white
hoping for
knight f2 i'm going to take with the
queen on b4 and i think this is the
critical idea behind white's rook takes
a5 no you don't want to get into this
why not
i'm saying you don't want to give it to
black to black well you can take on c3
but then queen takes b5
no i'm saying not this
previous
position
wait wait okay
take on c3 you take on c3 you're getting
everything okay so you hit everything
this is the current position
and we're not looking at knight f2 we
don't take on f2 we're taking on c3 and
we're taking with the bishop
with the queen of course
attack everything let's take with the
queen
now it feels like bishop d4 might also
be on tap in this position
thanks to that
knight on b4 right precisely
so rook takes b5 oh my goodness
how do you defend
uh did you like this or did you like
bishop d4 i think no no i like winter
too a lot okay
how do you defend no
we don't knights are covering absolutely
every single square in white's position
yeah the desirable rook a2 in order to
defend the bishop is met by well nothing
bishop and if you go queen to f1 try to
defend that bishop well there's no no
that bishop is not protected i can just
simply take on f2 as you cannot take on
f2 back because of bishop to d4
that rook is hanging as well yeah by the
way
one is the by the way no we're loving
this wow bobby is back in the hunt is
there a defense i gotta find out
queen c3 you know when i was in high
school a very popular song was by a
group hot chocolate
i believe in miracles
and for fabiano marijuana this would be
amazing he believes in miracles what a
comeback
wow
oh without question he was so far behind
but and we said something like he needed
a four and a half something like that
five
four wouldn't cut it well
he's making a fool of just right now i'm
gonna tell you
it's amazing it's defensible defensible
for white after queen takes c3 i don't
want to do a man
not in this i know you're not wrong with
that challenge you don't want this one
no no no but go ahead and play queen
take c3 okay which we already have my
board and now the move knight to f
three
not to f1
f3
challenge the bishop on e5 and guard the
d4 square okay
this is that's a good step i like that
key move in the defense and now if you
play knight takes f2
kill the bishop
on e5 not that one you need to kill the
most important piece dominating this is
the next thing you have to realize
actually is the main thing you have to
realize that that piece must die
that piece must die and after knight
takes e5
rook takes e5 then there's queen takes
g3
okay
which look i see knight takes h3 which
looks delicious i'm going to keep going
and now knight back ignore all of that
and play rook takes b5
good luck finding these moves i'm sorry
this is like all star
3 300 defense going on here now knight
takes h3 check
just take a
grab a little pawn king h1 yep
queen takes e5
presumably is best
bishop takes h3
by the way again
good luck finding this and
according to the engine right here
after knight c2 with a4
somehow someway
black is fine white is fine
we are
confused can we say it we don't know
what just all that analysis looked
ridiculous right to our eyes but that's
supposed to be the best way to play
and uh
and we we don't know like i don't think
anybody's fine if white if lindeman
finds these moves check his pockets
boss chair like and we're like no way
check his teeth to some kind of
something no way you find all these
moves i don't get to the finish line i
don't know how it came into my mind but
pre-computer analysis if i wrote a book
about my best games or something and i
gave this kind of analysis
everybody would be like
this guy needs to go to the institution
you know it's not working
and uh okay good luck alex
uh finding these moves but still fabi
has to still find the moves now himself
he does so it's a critical moment for
him and it's huge if he finds moves that
keeps the pressure and finally wins he's
in a four-way tie for first with one
round no
three-way type of thing not yet one but
grounds because to go with other games
still pending right also alex was not
looking for this type of game oh fabiano
caruana was looking for this guy
to get this such a position
though this is what you live for as a
champion it's in your hands your
destinies in your hands to find the
moves the only thing i will say is fabi
could fool himself
but he's not
take on c3 well i'm glad you don't have
to say it because he just played and if
we see knight f3 that would be
remarkable incredible but queen takes e3
but i've got to go back to these guys
are going head to head in terms of time
spent 15 minutes and 50 seconds for alex
london run 16 minutes for fabiano
they're very close and they have to both
of them have find difficult moves
absolutely i was about to say i'm going
to the gamer carissa and it looks like
coronation
something that i've seen and what is
that space invaders yeah that's four
right i'm sorry this is a nightmare baby
that's not it let's get that out of here
we want to see the charisma game yeah
this
how did the pawns even get in that
formation you might wonder
oh man well she started by giving them
she gave upon away on the f4 square she
gave up on away on the e5 square so
that's how we've got
d6 takes e5 and g5 takes f4 wow oh no
she only gave one pawn she still has
seven pawns on the board
what no she's talking about black game
white gay pawns white white white white
gave i was like seven pods
no but it is a piece it is a piece but
nobody can even count the pieces because
you're looking you're looking at these
mates down the h line you're like f3
it's just capturing this knight
f4 f3 is on black's agenda and oh my
goodness there's nothing okay if i'm
resignation i'm playing rook a3 closing
my eyes wrecking i'll i'll take that
i'll take that piece give me the piece
back give me the piece back he didn't
even think he did give me the peace
piece back right now it's time to go
is working i'm so proud i'm so proud you
know he came in this
into these broadcasts believing in
keeping his
queen
queen queen to david three no way we
don't believe any of it f3
we need more training all right all
right
and that's exactly what i want
to take the knight right not play f3 for
you to believe that i don't like taking
pieces and
okay you're still the expert
he's hunting
why why are you not really
willing to take a piece okay
okay i understand yeah you want to see
that on the board but f3
now after you allow knight g3 you're
right you're right you're right he knows
this is a disaster disaster
by the way as we said every single game
that she's won since she's lost
if you go study them
they're all beat down
one side no downs there's a question
come here i'm gonna attack you
and i'm gonna mate you
every game has been like that every game
her opponents have just been panicking
in the face of blistering threats and
attacks even even it's the ones that are
not that serious like
i'm gonna threaten you i'll do it again
let me just see if i do it again what
you do and they have just
been like whoa what's going on
five in a row
coming we said the bingo is on the way
do we have any doubts that this is over
the single most intimidating no the
single most intimidating uh uh player
i've ever seen is gary kasparov gary
kasparov put the fear
in his opponents and that seems to what
what's happened to carissa's opponents
by the way i really want to emphasize
this i mean she's 18 years old
she may have a career that well rivals
the great arena crush
of a modern day chess and uh
18 years old what i think it's a poor
deal i think it's important to know
as she has taken the piece thank you
very much and he's now up significant
material bishop there you go bishop on
g2 took the part on e4 you didn't take
the pawn on that forward and also she
played f takes e4 the way we are right i
expect but okay sorry sorry right now in
this moment
the thing i i want to emphasize for
carissa
she's been growing yeah you know we we
saw her talent a long time ago exactly
she's been growing and now she's just
dropped her knife back and said you're
not taking that and it's your move your
down material g3 could happen at any
point f3 could happen at any point i've
got mating ideas coming straight at you
right and you're going down here
uh
how many pawns down by the way is it
only two
only two pawns down it feels a lot more
a lot worse your king is exposed you
have no attack you've got one good piece
and that's bishop on e4 it's not doing
anything at all right now as no trades
possible and what are you supposed to do
you could resign with a clear conscience
in this position
as you're gonna lose but what i wanted
to say was yes please
carissa there's some sometimes when a
result
gives you the kind of confidence that
tells you it's time for me to grow get
better and go to the next level right
and this could just give her that
we've been watching carissa i saw her
talent when she was 12. and i picked her
way back when as
the future of
u.s women's chess she had such great
talent she had the attitude as well
and it took her a while
i'd been thinking my pick was off
because you saw other young ladies show
up jennifer you won a championship
anyway took care of business and it
looked like carissa was was she really
clear on the fact that how good she was
that interested in chess
well whatever she's done the rise has
worked she has broken through and now
she looks like a dominant force to deal
with for years to come in the women's
game at least her rating is still sub 2
500 i don't see why it shouldn't break 2
500. she has a lot of work to do to some
some aspects of her game
but man the way she looks right now she
she's going to be a problem
for the women's championship at least
hopefully she grows even more and starts
to knock on the world stage as well
playing in the open championship would
be uh pretty impressive as well for my
charissa became a certainty uh at the
cairns cup in 2019 she started terribly
zero out of three she bounced back
with two or three victories in a row one
of them including with the black pieces
against jew wen jun
the current world champion so at that
point i understood this lady is going to
be a star she's going to be the leader
of the american u.s olympic team
and this is what i'm seeing right now
she's certainly
living up to
the expectation of e5 by the way on the
board bishop d4 excuse me attacking e5
on the board that's just pure
desperation
at the moment just throwing the bishop
out of the way that allows f3
which is a statement move says you are
not surviving that and she only has one
minute and 29 seconds and there it is
she just has three she said what i don't
know what you did with your bishop but
let's talk about this f3 move
where i'm threatening to come down into
your position and dominate i'll take
that bishop later thank you very much
but right now i don't need to these are
two extra pawns i'm gonna use them
and we're gonna see in a moment she wins
this game
that's it and well it's not over because
irina has the winner has to not win yeah
that's exactly right i was looking at
the arena game and unfortunately for
arena fans including the fact that rita
was my pick
that game of arena just got up up on my
board nothing i think we'll just stay
with the other one because i think we're
going to see a rise again exactly
nothing has really changed actually
talia if anything has improved her
position by getting a rope to b4 so i'm
thinking unfortunately for arena fans
myself included
um
she's drawing that game 44 seconds left
as she studies this position we can take
a look at the clock we actually mind
when i have a delay on mine she's down
totally 26 and counting staring at this
position who would want to you're down
two pawns your king is is
looks like toast and you're gonna lose
more material very shortly and she's
down to 13 seconds and she's finally
given up a piece for a pawn so now she's
down a piece and a pawn
on this square we're thinking that's
just going to be a capture back and what
is
the problem here no problem at all
thank you very much again
to h1 queen to g2 is coming on the board
don't forget this is history in the
making exactly the only woman in u.s
championship history to defeat four
former champions that's according to our
cracker jack reporter ed gonzalez who
knows all things u.s championship at u.s
women's championship and there's a
resignation
history in the making she has done it
as far as beating four former champs the
only woman in the history of the game to
have done so she's won five in a row got
the bingo
and now waiting to see what happens in
the arena game as a draw will clinch her
the title what a dominating performance
i remember winning the 1986 u.s
championships the open i was like plus
six but i never defeated so many
former world champions in one event as
did carissa and there's the facts from
the usgs absolutely absolutely she has
defeated four former champions only
happened twice before in the open
section of the us chess championship
alex shibalov was first in 93 and then
joel benjamin in 97 still what an
accomplishment for these young 97 we're
talking about the way
24 years ago when it last happened she
wasn't even alive not not even close
not even close not even a thought in her
parents minds the parents hadn't met
and all eyes turn to arena if arena does
not win and keep the pressure up on
carissa uh we will have a new
u.s champion by the way and i think it's
been a repetition that's been going on
sorry what do you do right now as
arena take unnecessary risks no never
mind that's it this is it
is that it is asking for a draw right
now talia cervantes this is a three-fold
repetition
this will crown karissa
as the us women's national champion
wow
as talia points out
her intended move which will be a
three-time repetition
and we're seeing history in the making
as
irina has recognized that it's a draw
and she concedes
okay our congratulations to karissa yep
it's fantastic
25 000
uh
what an accomplishment for you gonna go
out to carissa and say can you pick up
the check
[Laughter]
she's picking up the truth
and she is right now with maurice ashley
after losing a terrible game she managed
to pick herself up and win five in a row
carissa let me say congratulations for
being the u.s women's champion for 2021.
thank you how does it feel right now
i guess it doesn't really sunk in but uh
i'm so happy i can't stop smiling so
i mean i was really surprised to win
this game because i was like
i was mostly thinking like yeah nazi's
like really solid with white i'll just
probably have to fight out for a draw
and then and then tomorrow just try not
to lose
so this was really a surprise you played
an opening that we thought was a little
bit shaky-ish like you didn't go solid
instead you played an opening the hippo
that
normally doesn't have a great reputation
yeah i don't know after
um
after she played d4 my prep was
i guess it was kind of iffy because i
was like i don't know what i'm gonna
play so i'm just gonna look at like a
bunch of different openings
and then while i was thinking about it i
was like
i feel like i'm fine entering like the
modern and like the hippo and stuff so
that's what i went for
all right you did get a
very
a cagey type position
and then
just when it looked like she was getting
a grip on those light squares you played
this
this uh speculative attack with h5
and then it was right at this moment
that she played a move that we fell off
our chairs to see the move f4 what did
you feel when you saw the move lane on
the board
i mean i was so surprised at f4 she
so she can't take on like g5 if she
doesn't play f4 right because there's
h4 and then after g4 like bishop takes
g4 ideas which is what i was going for
that sacrifice doesn't seem to be enough
compensation but then i thought if she
kind of just like sat around i wouldn't
be able to do anything
because
um
the engine does give knight a2 is saying
it's very solid for him yeah because
like kind of the whole idea behind my h4
combination is that the pawn on f2 is
left undefended after the bishop takes
on g5
but here in this variation um
bishop's still on e3 so
so i don't really have any more of my
tricks and so i was very surprised that
fyfa gave me like a lot of
a lot of good options
but um to say the least
yeah the one i liked the most was kind
of what i went for like with knight g4
so
and she was kind of already getting low
on time here so i thought it'd be like
really hard for her to play
yeah your attack just spoke uh volumes
by itself and just a winning attack and
we just saw this
real beat down as your queen showed up
and then she desperately tried to open
up the game pushing your pieces to just
great squares and you were able to
finish this off in style at the end what
a game carissa you beat four former
champions
in this tournament that has never been
done in the women's game ever only twice
in the open what are your thoughts about
doing that
i mean
it's very crazy but it wasn't um
i didn't know that it was kind of like
the first time this had happened so
so yeah kind of a surprise i guess
pleasant surprise pleasant indeed uh you
are now the champ you've got
friends who no doubt have been
supporting you through this event what
do you think they're feeling right at
this moment and would you like to thank
anyone um
yeah first i want to thank
um the kasparov trust foundation for
supporting me they've banned i've been
working with them for like
quite a few years now so it's really
great
i feel like it's done a lot for my
growth as a chess player and i also want
to thank my friends who are watching
everyone's like been texting me after
the rounds and they're all like let's go
and
it's really it's really nice to see them
following so closely
and
i want to thank my parents of course
because i couldn't be here without them
and they're probably watching right now
so hi guys
thank you so much for everything you've
done for me and
yeah
unbelievable fantastic results let me
just say you know we had to pick a
winner in this event on the very
beginning
and there are a couple of people who
have faith in you
me and var don't pay attention to the
peanut gallery over there as they didn't
pick you
just let's just get it straight so one
one check mark for for uh this side uh
carissa fantastic fantastic performance
the way you won
brilliant
now you've got one game to go it doesn't
matter for the score itself but a lot of
times you win the second to last game
and you get everything that last game
becomes a downer what is your attitude
going into that game
i mean
i don't really want to like affect my
mindset so i'll just go into the game as
usual
and
see how it goes but most of the stress
is off me now so yeah all right keep a
little bit of that stress you want to
make it six in a row possible
congratulations you are the u.s women's
champion for 2021. uh carissa first of
all our congratulations from the peanut
gallery over here well done um it's been
a source of speculation on a panel
uh who you work with as a trainer i said
that in the past it had been larry
christian said i know you're a samford
fellow which allows you to choose
basically
any trainer you'd like the support is
the financial support is that great who
have you been working with you mentioned
the kasparov chess foundation
uh
tell us
um
yeah so in recent years i don't really
have a
very steady coach
usually i just work with um
i work with people once
like right before a big tournament
but like on the usual i don't really
don't really do much okay um
so i would have to say
probably alex ownership i've been
working with these few years so
yeah nice so big shout out to alex yeah
something's working between you two
again
charissa first of all my congratulations
at the middle of the tournament it's
felt it felt like you are in a slump
but after that
maurice roasted you was that a catalyst
for your revival winning five games in a
row and winning a national championship
definitely you know i was i was so hurt
by liz rose like this can't ever happen
again i have to play to play so much
better i can't that's that's all we do
that shows your toughness that shows
that you can take criticism it shows
you're a champion and that's how it
works if i had roasted chris christian
would have just wilted
why'd you say that
that's not how champions do that's how
it works we'll be honest when you play
bad you play bad when you play great
you're a champ that's how we like it yes
again
bingo as we say five in a row well done
good luck carissa in the last game don't
lose your focus
yes i won't celebrate your victories
[Laughter]
what do you have chris and there it is
once again
applause
2021 u.s women's champion
well done young lady fantastico
as arena crush has drawn her game she
was the only one in contention
right and that is over let's jump
quickly to the game of fabi as well as
the other games in the open bobby seems
to have blown it no
he missed a vicious move his best move
in and he has allowed linderman back in
the fight no that would be disastrous it
was right here after queen bishop e3
that he needed to take on g3
and just open up that rook to attack the
bishop as easy peasy just a very direct
move he could have played a king
taking a pawn as well and he would have
had a great position instead he traded
bishops directly that bishop on e5 as
you mentioned was the monster that was
really assaulting alex's position a
trade f4 g4 we've caught up with the
players
now this still looks
how could this not be winning i mean it
still looks very difficult for white the
engine's giving triple zeros by the way
no way yes saying that there's
queen f2 knight f3 rookie two queen g3
my goodness i would have thought that
this is just dead busted triple zeros i
couldn't be more surprised
but we do have another special guest
here in the studio with us irina crush
eight time national champion is with
maurice ashe yes we're with irina and
irina i guess you do know the news that
the youngster has won the championship
your thoughts about her performance yeah
well congratulations to carissa she just
had an amazing tournament just we won
five games in a row it was uh hard to
keep up with that
absolutely your game was a tough game
with talia she played a solid opening a
lot of space when you got the black
pieces it happens
yeah i mean i'm trying with the black
pieces you know i'm trying to play some
exciting openings but somehow i've had a
few of these moroxy bind structures that
have been hard to play for a win and i
mean you know i even felt like i was you
know on the easier side of this end game
today but still i mean it's a very solid
position for white and i just didn't see
any way to continue the game you made
this point about keeping up with her uh
you could have a great result and not
win the tournament looks like you're
having a great result now yeah like i
mean i'm it's not the worst you know u.s
championship i've ever played i mean
i've had some pretty good games i've
done well with the white pieces um you
know i think mainly it was you know the
slow start you know two out of four
was uh not so good after that it's
gotten better but still you know when
someone wins all their games and even if
you play decently you know you can't
always manage to do that so
you know i could kind of see the writing
on the wall when i saw her win against
nazi i was like okay you know um i guess
this is not my uh my tournament to win
you got one more game to go is the
motivation high oh it's high yes of
course i mean i'm going to do everything
i can in the last round to finish as
well as i can i know even if you can't
win you should still
try to get the best place that you can
that's the champion's attitude good luck
tomorrow uh we hope to see the best from
you thank you maurice yes indeed arena
good luck
uh to you and uh i'm still a little bit
stunned about the news of fabiano's
position not
let's and by the way lanier dominguez
was a half a point in the trailers
please christian he drew against jeffrey
shanks so that is a big result i thought
at some point dominguez had something to
work with in that game
unfortunately his king was compromised
if i
if i recall that game i just yeah at the
end it doesn't surprise me that it ends
in a perpetual and by the way the game
between lenderman and fabiano caruana
well lenderman has five minutes for the
next ten moves fabiano corona eight
minutes so that one is going to get
wildness and ray robson holy smokes two
pawns for a piece uh rey is not winning
this i would say let's just jump into
that game with fabi because that is the
baby i am still mystified as to why
fabi's not winning and the engine is
telling us triple zeros probably missed
that chance by the way that showed that
precise defense is extremely difficult
but bishop takes g3 was the way to go
that said
as we're saying it's going to not be so
easy to defend this position but there
is a plus
as far as alex is concerned as we see a
move did get played and played very fast
the way
this last move was going to stay with
the board rook
e2 okay
i mean again it's quite aggressive it
looks like it's smashing
it makes a great impression that move
knight to f3
but then queen to f
no i'm going to take the bishop with
check no that's winning yes yes so
knight of three and that's not a queen f
two and nine takes
check is not possible what about queen g
one your bishop queen g1 your bishop on
b5 is hanging i do i okay so first of
all let's refute knight f3 knight f3
whoops this is the nasty killer
instant
that is three pieces probably mate
coming that is it this is game so we we
can't do that there is a bishop hanging
on b5
uh but
i think we just
uh shouted out queen g1 right through g1
was an option and i was thinking oh
sorry it's a big question right please
do you want to go to e5 or to d5 i do
like taking another pawn so let's let's
go with that
nice
thank you thank you so much you do like
taking another pawn which by the way
defends the bishop it it's you you're
eyeballing the f4 f3 and rook takes d2
move how does white stay in the game
king h1
he's got to get out and now this guy's
move
by the way bishop to c6 no doesn't work
why not it's gorgeous takes the rook on
a5 oh no there's a rook on a5 i know i
know i missed it too oh
it's oh
oh
wow talk about by the way he did not
play queen to g1 he played rook to a8
and that is the best move by the way g1
was another move as well queen g1 did
work by the way
pinning the bishop now keeping that out
the game
is also a good line now queen g1 has to
so let's understand why you cannot go
out with the king yeah
thanks to g7 king h6 that seems like a
safe spot g5 check and i in the knight
no not f3 not king eight okay he played
bishop e8 importantly absolutely foreign
all forced every move right now force
for alex for alex he's finding defense
he's playing precise chess
right now now we can't take on d5
because there's queen takes
e rook takes pca check this is brilliant
played by both players right now okay
he's only 359 on his clock alex playing
like a boss defending fabi missed his
best chance now he's got to hope his
opponent does not play like a machine
the rest of the way
okay hold on hold on so we're looking
for the best move here
for black
looking queen b2 possibilities
i'm looking it is the best move queen b2
queen beach
okay but then i was a little bit afraid
of a knight c4
knight c4s tickling b2 as well as d6 and
i'm hesitating once i see that move
unless
i've got something with f3 queen f6
queen f6 what a maneuver that's bizarre
luring the knight to a would-be very
bizarre so that i can play for f3 though
because you don't normally need four
every day
right if you go queen f6 first i can go
knight to e4 and that's big trouble for
black and you're hitting yeah e8 you
won't believe the best move here
king h1 because i said you don't believe
the best move you should find it
the threat is f3 g5 probably the no the
threat is f3 no no
i've got to go king h1 no no
okay so he's not g5 all right
that's back to d2 oh get out of
[Music]
was here running down the street at the
central west end
that's christian and yes
we're we're bringing brick and brax uh
jason don't hate the messenger
i'm just reporting the news but the
second
sequence is insane that's an insane
they're not going to play like this well
will he play queen b2 though yes in the
first place he will will he fight queen
btw because queen b2 looks very
aggressive hitting that knight and then
you can play for queen f6 on the next
move so this is what we're saying
this is the current game and they're
related queens e2 is on the board and
now we'll there's no way knight c4 queen
of six knight back to d2 no if alex
finds knight d2 check his pockets give
him the national championship
i agree with maurice on that one give
him the national championship to defend
this position he's uh
hold on so let's just think there's
wesley who's undefeated lenderman is
undefeated i thought there was a third
undefeated
is it linear
yes
no sam of course is lost
he's he's he's got the best number of
victories so it's so nice
by the way knight f3 is another move
knight f3 isn't it and that's the word
he plays that's the one you're playing
oh come on he's played it everybody
would play knight f3 that's the human
human move but what happened now if you
are black knight takes d5 why
to eat another pawn thank you
you take 95.
you might be resigning because of knight
d4 i understand but i'm just saying
uh there's another no there's another
move knight c no i
you know what i really wanted to do i
wanted to pick up the knight on b4 and
transfer to e3 overlooking the fact that
my room
the the the bishop on e8 is
best move
king king hey best move guard your
bishop
position he's fine they're finding
top-notch moves folks
like high
d4
from my calculations don't tell me that
right now the players have to repeat
with king h1 knight f2 that would be
that is very possible
i don't think bobby wants it but that is
very possible
but his time is ticking down he's
actually i got it 301 and he's feeling
look at him he just shook his head he's
got to make six moves i was thinking
seven moves you gotta love this king h1
knight f2 check king back i'm not going
to go back to d3 i'm going to go back to
e4
why so that after king h1 it can bring
the other night
the other night to the party make sure
to invite everybody to the party when
you're attacking a critical moment right
now for white two and a half minutes for
alex linder
by the way the move you just suggested
is a blunder king h1 king h1 king no
king h1 let's show this line and i got
it he's about to panic
everybody it's insane what he has to
worry about you cannot put your knight
on e4 uh
you mean knight f2 check king h294 yes
bad move because
well we need to see the board in order
for it
a8
to e8 but here we go if you play you
play knight f2 khan
knight yeah
rook takes ea check and you're getting
mated yeah what the queen is coming to
a7 oh my gosh like queen on g-1 lurking
getting ready to join the party are you
kidding me kidding is
not what's happening and
the the major pieces the rook and the
queen do it on their own power
king to have six rook tours
and that's mate so fabi has to be
careful he might even lose the game and
lindemann would be in seoul first
if that happens
first he has to make a move
before he has to make sure he's gonna
move what is happening right here he's
feeling the pressure and he sees that
check by the way he sees the knight of
two checking he has nothing to do but
bring his king back so he probably wants
to make a progress move not something
where his opponent gets to choose what
happens next so he's
frozen here with only a minute and
seven seconds left
going down to his final millions
you can see him going back and forth
alex at the moment and rook to a7 a move
that wasn't on our horizon we have seen
and instantly
h7 h6 it was like
wow he said i know what you're going to
do
putting the pressure on his opponent but
he's not the best move the engines don't
like this move and think that g5 is
better for white the game has turned as
g5 away c5 is supposed to be better for
white i don't know what's wrong with h5
oh h5 is a little bigger
maybe knight to h4 it's amazing they can
be so dismissive of
the threats along the second rank that
seem
g5 is dangerous folks this is
potentially winning if he finds it if g5
if i may just quickly play this out if
g5 is played
right very quickly right right here yeah
just let me show that i'll show it in
three seconds i promise you producer g5
if you decide not to open the line
suddenly you're getting mated tates and
queen to b6 and you're in deep trouble
in this position with the rook
sorry rook if rook takes are getting
mated that's what i meant if rook takes
her getting made because there's no
queen f6 there's no queen coming back
because the pawn controls the square so
g5 is a very strong move let's see if he
finds it in this position
and he's down to only eight 18 seconds
can he find this
g5 guards the f6 square and he's not
finding it he's gonna be seven seven
instead a very natural move uh either
wanting to double on the eighth
as well as pinning the knight on
b4 what is black going to do right now
black is this is why he doesn't have any
understanding right now black doesn't
have any threats fabi himself at least
he has six minutes on the clock
that's one benefit but black doesn't
have any threats white has frozen out
black's game
that's crazy
defense wins championships they say in
sports this is what's happening right
now this is crazy he's defending like a
beast
i'm having a very very hard time
believing that uh
black hasn't got winning threats here
holy this game will go down in the
history books oh yeah regardless of the
regardless of the result
we haven't seen such a competitive game
in a very long time yeah or three
results possible for the last i don't
know 10 odd moves you remember that game
between mamadirov and richard report in
that one down to one second
this is what this is feeling like
heavyweight battle the per first person
blink loses the game and now fabi's
staring in the position saying what am i
supposed to do right now he does have
the move knight to e5 i like that move
the game going it doesn't mean that he's
white is better right now by the way
according to the engines but knight to
e5 bringing that knight back i'm sure
that's not the move he wants to play but
he's gonna have to bite the bullet at
some point and realize his attack is not
crashing through anymore and he's got to
be wary of white's threats well knight
e5 by the way does have an immediate
threat obviously of knight takes f3
check and if you play knight takes e5
queen takes e5 we get out of the pin
and we simultaneously pick up a massive
threat in f4 f3 this is the current
position and we do like knight e5 just
well the problem there he has is after
95 queen e5 yes yes which he's done he's
found 95 95 queen e5 there is suddenly
the move queen a1 yeah good luck finding
that what
what
oh my god
just offering the trade of queens
no he's going to play king h1 what
happens after king h1 is the question
he's never going to find queen a1 with
39 seconds yeah that was my question i
was no wait in king h1 i was thinking
that in case of king h1 by the way my
intention was to play knight takes d5
and
h1 this kid is playing this position
this young man showing what he's got
that that takes
fighting spirit courage but
boldness
amazing that is a heart-stopping move i
know
i know oh my excuse me but what if i
take on f3 right now and follow it up
with rook to e3 knight takes f3 bishop
takes f3 rook to e3 i'm still in these
very awkward pins though
christian
knight f3 bishop f3 rookie three okay
let's take a look at the camera right
now concretely exactly
now
i could go on the attack
rook to e8 instead of defending my
bishop
i'll uh i like that movie i'll um how do
i say uh i'll i'll see the thread now
you do have more than uh equality if i
take on f3 and you take on e8
and i go king i've got that queen a7
f7 it doesn't matter i got that queen a7
check and that kills me on the spot
exactly so we can't do that we can't
take the bishop after
knight takes f3 bishop takes f3 rookie
three and now i go queen to d2
i want to go rook to e1
are you so sure because i'm getting
closer to you though
all right all right all right oh boy oh
boy
g5
because i've i've got ideas of g types
h5 yeah and then i want oh rook h3 mate
oh
by the way
i can also take on uh g5
yeah i wanted to take and go g6 and g7
i'm forgetting about rook h3 no i can
take on g5
the pawn when you play g5 i can also
also you can take it okay so queen d
oh whoops excuse me queen d2
uh fabiano senses something he paused
on the clock there is nothing for fobby
by the way he's just
he's just playing chess with his
opponent right now
and we're waiting to see will he play
rook to e3 which looks like i like yours
he is christians
i was going to call you christians i
know i apologize christian
there's only one
christian
whoa
what to e5 we did not suspect
that move absolutely not and now
what this one is
he's eyeing the e the d5 pawn which
looks completely irrelevant to the
position what the heck
now by the way there's a queen a1
sighting again queen a1 you're not
attacking anything in white's position
you're giving white complete liberation
as to what to do next and three moves of
time control if you place queen a1 he's
threatening potentially to bring his
queen into the game at some point but
brook takes e8 is also on top
big move queen a1 right now
because the problem after queen a1 you
have to exchange the queen
you can't avoid it rookie eight will
he's not saying it but rook e3 was he's
reaching for the rooks right now how
could he not have played rookie he wants
to play rook b8 i think look it's seven
seconds seven
count
he wants to
play what is that what is going on we
can't guess the moves
rook to c8
that can't be good i can't be good and
now queen d2 is possible queen d2 is
playable here as that last move queen a1
was best how many moves left still two
for white three
time control each time alex is dropping
under 10 minutes now
seconds i meant to say sorry he played
it with three seconds on the clock
you're mcqueen d2 you were showing me
this opportunity a moment ago when there
was a rook on e3 i even like the then
the queen d2 now
is
is a dream move because now you're
you're you get out of the pin
so how do you defend against rook to e1
exactly and knight d3 so queen deets yes
queen g2 guys queen g2 will
hold the ship together
are you so sure i don't know it's not me
oh that's a computer trust me okay i'm
just reporting it right we're just
trying to get it what's what's going on
with the night
this is with the knight able to move
can't i just prance it
and
my goodness
oh
wow probably you have to drop on c2
right now with the rook and try to
exchange the rooks with rookie too
wow i
okay guys
we got to do it predict the game we got
it this one this one
this one let's do it
that's insane
that's insane predictor is a user
quit
the producer just quit that idea in the
bud yeah we don't look like idiots by
the way
it's too crazy i think it's fabulous
let's just say this is just too too hard
to defend
and i think after
we do i'll go with the draw
you go i think fabi's gonna win with
queen d2
i just don't see how alex can withstand
it's kind of like the charissus yip
school of chess you just attack attack
attack attack
there's two more moves before he has all
the time in the world he escapes 30
minutes
it's not
all that i get the point
but yeah queen d2 let's go the thing is
white's actually the one now who's in
more control of the game than black
black has one threat black has one
threat but black is
doesn't have enough pieces to dominate
white's position
like if you were giving away
two on the board all right here is
the most and he's already been looking
at queen d2 so he's preparing for it
he's going for rook to c1 that's too
passive
that cannot be a good move
knight to d3 what's happening right now
aren't you completely lost
after rook
move has changed the game
dramatically as fabi is much not much
better winning would be too strong a
word but this move is a blink this one
is definitely passive
as he's now released the bishop off of
e8 as well so that's a big deal that you
suddenly you're not worried about any
rook takes e8 tactics yeah yeah
instead remember he is in fresh under
pressure but knight d3 looked wonderful
in that moment
okay i understand you play knight d3 the
rook is going to go somewhere then you
play rookie three you have the idea of
bringing the knight back to e5 that's
the the boss square e5 to protect us
where you're hitting the base what
happens if he attacks the queen
that's the move right now the the the
the knight on b4 needs
protection final move for alex landerman
you missed a golden chance under 10
seconds and now with only five four
three
row
one
that's a why don't you three two seconds
you're right this absolutely that wasn't
you should have played rook d1 and got
his tempo he played rook f1 under the
pressure and now fabi's back he could
play knight d3 or bishop f7 both moves
are good for him and he will have an
advantage at the time control that he
will get a chance to milk alex missed
his chance right at the critical moment
you mentioned rip richard rapport and
shaq mamidara yes where it was like
two seconds he played this final move
maurice with yeah i remember richard did
it with one yeah
he was under so much pressure he didn't
want to attack the queen in this moment
he was afraid of something
in that position and now fabi can play
again knight d3 or bishop f7 that rook
used to be on a8
pinning that bishop suddenly that bishop
could get a little bit of life on the f7
square the knight could go to d3 and
freeze white's position
time travel makes fools of us all but if
you consider the last three four moves
of alex it's basically been all rook
moves
black hasn't made that much progress but
once you see that knight
land on the e5 along with the rook on e3
that's it folks that's all she wrote
game over knight d3 put the and by the
way put the pawn on g5 too
i mean if i'm going to ask for things
let me ask for everything protected pass
pawn on the f4 square
making bishop g6 also possible knight d3
knight e3 plane and we are at times
we're going to see a massive tie for
first well it's not it's not nearly over
yes it's not nearly over the engine
disagrees with you just wait a minute i
think this is a time for a human versus
machine machine because this looks like
a come on we're cruising here
oh okay well we can do it if you want
human versus machining because there's a
feeling
are you ready are you ready super
confident are you ready
i think black has it all everything all
right well it's time to breathe
let's just be clear fabi wins this game
and he's tied for first right if he does
win the game right and draws then
lenderman stays tight for first bobby
still has a chance along with west
finally sam i what is this him and if
lindemann wins he is in seoul first with
a heroic defense right all right rook b3
let's go rook b3 rook boy three
okay that's that's a real pity because i
was so wanting to play knight e5
i'm going to get a chance you you want
to play that move g5 okay i want to play
bishop to g6 now queen to g2
trapping your queen essentially me too
unless you're gonna fly all the way back
out to a5
queen the g that forces uh the trait of
the queens
yasser inside of two moves
oh no i'm not that happy anymore queen
takes g2 how do we recapture with the
bishop
king takes king king
you're allowing knight to e1
yeah it wants to get rid of that piece
okay knight to e1 has to be played
should we take the rook on b3 or the
rook on e1 which one do we prefer wait
did he take only one yes oh they did
yeah
take the rook on e1 i feel let's take
that one and we don't want one
rook b6
you think he's got a fortress
this is a dream benoni
a dream bononi you put your king on e5
it is
defending all the parts
michael all the parts i think it was
mike no it wasn't michael maron uh it
was
another famous romanian grandmaster bad
bishops
protect good pawns yep yep and it was uh
i'll remember his name i apologize to
he wrote a marvelous book on the
hedgehog it might be uh
good construction for white yeah
blockade
so i so where upon up and the ninja's
not impressed
wow i'm just not impressed by this i am
oh we have
we
oh sam shanklin has just won his game
dining room
and by the way sam
will be up against fabiano tomorrow so
this kind of
you know
i don't want my opponents to come you
oh my god okay well i'll leave this with
the engine and i'll just say that for me
this was more or less an ideal i thought
that's still not that easy though but
okay not at all i mean my goodness by
the way fabio is going to play for hours
oh if he gets well
he's going to play and play and play
and the reality that white faces here is
that black's the one who's playing for
the win so he might stare down a
position like this one and say i don't
want to play it to play queen g2 and
accept the fact that you're gonna be
worse
and have to defend for a long time
against fabian caruana that's going to
be very difficult reality to accept but
we're going to give you everybody we're
going to give the win to the machine
this time because
it's very difficult to break that
fortress indeed
but uh that this position
you might be right yes in practical
terms maybe winning
for
black well a long way to go however yeah
and for a human
player i mean by the way uh just just as
a grand master you're sitting there
castled
on the king side and your queen has been
stuck on g1 and you know your queen's
not going to happy next to your king
playing this you know incredibly passive
role as as a defender you're not feeling
very good as a human player machines
don't mind they don't care about good
pieces or bad pieces they they have
their algorithms
for me i think it's all
uh fabio this is going to be a titanic
task for alex to defend this he does
power too first of all he survived to
this point
we do have a guest right now in the
studio with maurice that is former u.s
champion sam shangri
yes we are with former champ sam
shanklin sam a good win for you it seems
though that you're not feeling so
thrilled about your performance i mean
would you be thrilled with my
performance come on i'd be happy with
that score actually if i were in your
shoes but i know you're a different
caliber player yeah it's certainly been
a very rough tournament just like the
exhaustion was not easy i've not been
feeling great and honestly i haven't
been sleeping that well in some of these
rounds but you know i'm i'm glad that
even one
feels like the world is collapsing on me
i can still play a reasonable game and
keep my head on straight and fight till
the end because
you know
i was at least happy to win one game or
not two but it you know
yeah
apologies because we were following
other games uh in the mix
uh
if we if i may switch out because
there's a performance that happened here
in carissa yip that reminded me of your
performance when you won your
championship you just started winning
everything and dominating uh what are
your thoughts about how this young lady
has done well more power to her i've
spoken with her now and i don't know i
think she has a lot of potential and a
great job i fully expect her to make it
to grandmaster and beyond in the coming
years if she keeps taking it as
seriously as she is now
um i would caution her against playing
the hippopotamus in important games
when she starts playing stronger events
than us women's but uh no it's certainly
great to see a promising young american
have success like that
absolutely your thoughts watching the
open itself plus two with everybody all
bunched up
like this it's incredibly
demoralizing of course i mean when i won
this tournament plus six and like so i
just felt like if i'd been even remotely
reasonable for him i'd have like very
serious chances to fight i'm like only a
point out of first despite playing like
horrible really horrible chess the whole
way through so
it's a little demoralizing but hey i
mean there i think there was a euro plus
three won the tournament as well so but
i guess look if all the top players are
tired and you know the the 2800s you're
playing like 2700s and 2750s you're
playing like 26.75 then you know the
guys who are starting at that rating
have every bit of a chance to fight if
they're in good form so i don't know i
haven't really been following very
closely i've just been trying to focus
on my own games but i guess it's set up
for an exciting finish
that's what i was going to ask you you
said you're not following very closely
who you think maybe
comes out of this i i don't no i if it's
not going to be me at this point so
beyond that i don't really care i mean i
i just played badly and in a year where
really if anybody had played remotely
well they would have just run away with
the tournament but so far nobody
everyone's just playing bad so
you know that's how it goes plus two or
plus three will win this year but you
know stranger things have happened all
right well thanks so much for joining us
and good luck in your last oh wait a
minute you play fabian the last game
which may be a necessary win for him
your attitude going into that one it's
just another game just play it like any
other
i mean all right good luck sure thank
you uh for joining us sam and good luck
tomorrow in uh the championship
round and i by the way please
alex lenderon did not play rook to b3
he immediately played the move yes queen
to g2
and that is losing
on the spot
losing to queen c3
which father played
that is losing on the spot now it is
totally
totally he missed that retreating move
yes he missed the treaty moves are the
hardest ones to see
queen to c3 another retreating move by
the way he missed rook b3 one retreating
move queen c3 the second retreating
mufabi did not miss it and now the
threats are real 91 is definitely
on top really and white's pieces are
suddenly disjointed the one piece that
needed to be back in the defense the
rook on b7 needed to be on b3 and now
suddenly
fabi has the game completely under
control and a win gives him a tie for
first that is a cold shower right now
for alex van der rohe
and once again
i believe in miracles because
fabi was so
far we moved from he was at a minus
score
and the leaders uh was it ray robson
one plus two so there was the one as
well and look at that start ugly uh
no reason to think that he could come
back after coming from a minor score has
anyone in the history of the
championship yeah ever i want ed
gonzalez to take a deep dive because i
think they can't tell you the truth
thing anyone come back from a minor
score in after round six
well what i was going to say is i think
somebody like a larry christensen uh you
know who is notorious for going through
uh tournaments with no draws might have
once suffered two losses and tied for
first but i don't think anybody won a
championship
suffering back-to-back losses but also
this late and being on a minus score i
can understand
yeah that's crazy
you're supposed to be cooked after that
we may have another bit of history in
the making as i'm sure ed will be
texting me soon maurice uh it ain't
never happened nobody comes back after
round six by the way for the minor score
would that be three and a half out of
four in his last four rounds
oh yeah i think so
three and a half out of the four because
he's gonna be we were saying that we
need he needed to go four out of five or
four and a half four and a half
five and a half out of five four out of
five might do it right
and then we have a completely different
discussion but excuse me the guy's gonna
have his chest stuck out if he wins this
game and he's tied for first and he's
got an edge on sam shanklin who we just
saw in here who has no desire to play
this tournament anymore but knows he'll
be hunted by caruana in that game
without any question about it white
fabby with white two wins
in their individual matchups but if
there is one professional player that
will play all the way until the end no
matter the result no matter of his
situation in the tournament is that is
sam shanklin
yeah
he's going to take it professionally
he's going to defend if he has course he
is he's going to have the best
preparation possible going into that
round and fabiano carona will have to
show his medal in order to win that
championship yeah
and by the way earlier i had mentioned
samford
fellows so sanford
created a fund that was there to support
upcoming
boys and girls with a two-year i believe
it is now 25 000 it might be as much as
30 000
per year for their training and there
you have a look at the fellows and look
at the winners over there 2021 carissa
yet alex linderman 2011.
um where is sam sevion 2015 a lot of
familiar names and a big shout out
to samford for his generosity
and what a legacy
he has created absolutely and we see
carissa abe right now the 2021
samurai san francisco exactly by the way
i don't know if she was being a little
bit cagey
i know magnus is very very cagey when
they ask him so who are you working with
for this world championship against nepo
uh she was working with alex anashuk
during the cairns cup two years ago as
well okay
i know that i didn't know that they
continued their collaboration thereafter
right so sometimes you don't want people
to know who you're training with because
if you had known for example in the 2018
world championship match you might have
guessed especially nikov could have been
in uh magnus's reputation if we knew
that duboff is his second president that
was one of the seconds we did not know
so a lot of players
like
not to release that information i was
kind of fishing there yeah who who would
you like to by the way
this matchup i wanted to say between
fabi
and sam shanklin there's no love lost in
that game because
don't forget sam famously
was a second for magnus
against fabi right in their in that
match in the world championship and
also the one championship that fabi had
a real chance to win
where he win plus five as you're at sam
say excuse me i win plus six right and
took that away from you right so you
know
fabi's like yeah by the way i mean it'd
be a nice one to win this one i think
you were mistaken about that one i don't
think he was a second in 2018 he was in
2016 against karayaki that is for sure i
don't think in 2018
was a second of magnus okay all right
perhaps he's going to be a second for
this upcoming championship right and i i
do remember hosting a party in that
championship where you know i was
looking at fabby and fabby is like i
just don't understand it
i i mean i'm tied for first and i score
two and a half out of three i'm saying
give me the winner's check the other guy
scores three out of three and i'm clear
second that was a remarkable victory by
sam shanklin
and let's take a look at some results
absolutely well we're going wow to start
with the open section what a date has
been shankland won against naruto
savion
a very interesting draw against the west
very important draw very important we
haven't checked in on robson burke well
robson is still playing but we have
jeffrey sean drew dominguez another
important and right now landerman
fighting for survival against fabiano
caruana
and in the latest section we did crown a
winner a national champion that is
karissa who took down
former national champion
nazi pakistan es warren won against
zatonski and a draw was in cervantes
versus crush guys if we haven't had
enough excitement we again we do have a
new u.s women's champion 18 year old
karissa yep
uh out
fighting arena crush
the eight time but if we haven't had
enough excitement with the leaders in
the open section and what's going on i
think ray robson is winning he's got
three pawns
for a night
and
yeah
baby
ray
don't forget about ray ray ray ray ray
definitely trying fabiano may be you
know all that
uh top rated and everything i i cannot
see him winning this yes oh so easy oh
easily if i put my king on g2 my pawn on
f3 my king on g3 pawn on g5
oh pardon me my pawn on h4 and h5
i think it's over i think the knight
does not i think a bishop
is the right
uh
my case
right now is black i think the last move
was raised what if i try to force the
exchange of one of uh the pawns with
rook to e5
rook to e5
we're up to e5 that's a serious move oh
my gosh i want to play f5 the problem is
i cannot play five right now because you
take and you have rook f3
so i want you to put the pawn on f3
first and then i go great idea oh my
gosh sorry i may have
simply missed this by the way he did it
he played rook to c4 rook to c4 was my
main line actually i did not i apologize
let me just show what the the to the
audience what you're saying that if i
have to play f3
uh how about you this is
i
i understand that
i want to play knight versus three right
but i don't want to have a split
structure i would love to have the h3
pawn on the g2 or g4 square and i'm
going to play that forever i may not win
it but i will play it for you as long as
they're connected you're actually right
but i think after f5 you do have rook to
d3 okay show me again so three five f
three f five
f three
and f5 what about no rook to d3 you just
take on e4 that's what i was afraid yeah
okay okay but unfortunately for rey
his opponent wasn't going to keep the
structure together by the way there was
a wave oh please tell me how yeah just
take after rookie five f3 yeah
f5 f5 just take it
oh oh
[Laughter]
you hypnotized me
i advertise myself as well
nicely done uh those are hidden moves
the hidden move with the ideas that you
take i will take and his chances oh very
very very good practical chances uh
three connected pass bombs although yes
sir i mean if this knight come on we're
able to reason
that's for sure but if the knight ever
plays knight takes at five
i mean maybe you won't give it to me i
understand
tonight
i'll show it to the audience so what
maurice is saying is one of the
difficulties to win this type of ending
of three uh pawns is
when you play move like f5 you have to
be
aware
that you get in those situations where
the
um
the split pawns h3 and f5 aren't good
enough to win
uh so you nurse them slowly you go to
the alex lenderman school of chess you
play a lot of moves you go h4 you play a
lot of moves you go h5 and then when
your tone is exhausted is when you play
straight
just to keep the night at bay you don't
want to see the knight landing
potentially on your doorstep
of f3 but okay again white's white's
goal is very clear he wants to make slow
slow incremental progress and rey should
rey win
he was a half a point behind i believe
he's joining the pack of dealers that's
what i'm saying this will be a five-way
tie we're going to be on this one for a
while
five-way time
going into the championship i can't
remember any u.s championship where
whether it's that many players tight for
free round robin because i do remember
there was a 10-way tie
in the one championship i played in i
think it was 2003 in seattle in seattle
it was a 10-way tie eight ga eight
players four games drew immediately
right and it was shabbalov versus var
exactly and shabbat pressed and pressed
and beat var to win that and one by
himself right but there was a 10 way tie
at the top
again that was an open that was ornament
right not
the clothes that we by the way guys yes
please well
john found the move knight to d6 and i
think that kind of closes the show oh oh
what
and this game has ended i think this is
uh
oh darius
yeah okay
uh lazara grizzan who had drawn i think
his first five maybe six five games yeah
six games uh proving a very very tough
man to beat suddenly he's tumbled as
he's lost three he lost to jeffrey zhang
in a brilliant uh that was a queen h8
yeah a game that marie showed us on the
show our brilliancies and blunder
segment and now again today
uh and he lost against the
somebody else's yeah there was an
earlier loss as well and i'm just saying
these guys they sense that weakness that
little blood in the water and they go
for it so uh
[Music]
congrats to darush and as we started the
show i asked you the question
what happens in case of a type
three or four players are tied for first
then we're going to have a rapid
round-robin event okay
that's going to be gaming 10 minutes
with a two-second delay now that delay
just explained that to me for a second
so we've been seeing the increment
throughout 30 second increments
a delay means precisely what so
increment is whenever you make a move
you gain an additional 30 seconds i love
it delay you don't get any extra seconds
your time starts ticking down after a
delay of two seconds okay so one one two
and now your clock starts running down
so i can never increase you can never in
time on the clock which a lot of players
try to do precisely when they're behind
on the clock so okay continue sorry two
players and after that if two players
are still tied we're going to have a two
game blitz mini match that once again is
going to be gaming three plus two delay
okay if three or four players are still
tied after this rapping round robin
we're going to have a blitz
round robin gaming three plus two delay
and that is if we have three or four
players what happens in case two players
are tied if we have two players tied for
first going into the playoffs we're
going to have a two game rapid match
game in 10 minutes with a two second
delay if after that the players are
still tied 1-1 we're going to go
straight into an arm again and the
armageddon game is a what game well
that's when mayhem ensues on the board
if armageddon white gets five minutes
black gets four minutes for the whole
game if the game ends in a draw black
wins there's absolutely no increment no
delay is going to be madness white gets
an extra minute but black gets draw odds
okay got it all right but we do have a
guest in studio we do have a guest who
is with maurice darius virg after a
tremendous victory
indeed a great victory for him darius
this tournament has not been one where
you're fighting for first i know you'd
rather be in that position but getting a
good win closer and seemingly more and
more solid as this tournament has gone
on uh you've been holding your own
i mean yeah
the tournament is
over in the sense of me playing for the
top places but still there is you know i
thought after yesterday there are still
two games to go
uh let's just play chess do my best and
see how it goes of course it's better to
finish the tournament uh with i mean not
with a loss of course
so uh yesterday it was a tough game for
me of course but uh you know i've tried
to forget about and just try to do my
best in the last two rounds so far
according to the plan hopefully tomorrow
will be the same
you i know you have other tournaments
coming up yes your next tournament is uh
feeder ground swiss is the grand swiss
is this allowing you to see where the
holes are or maybe patch up some
difficulties definitely definitely it's
a great uh you know preparation i mean
like
we die
and we still i mean like i was forgotten
the same going it's like we die and we
we are born uh stupid and we die stupid
like or something like that right that's
i think it's polish
so uh basically what i'm trying to say
is like every day is learning experience
so uh
yeah like i'm very happy to
you know play here and because
each game
you know is against very strong player
so i can learn something from it better
to play well in the next tournament yes
definitely as you're trying to qualify
for the world championship uh you see
this tournament you see how bunched up
it is
at the top
do you feel like just a little bit
different than you could have maybe been
in the mix i mean definitely like i
missed this tournament i missed a couple
of chances uh like against alexander man
samshankland both games i in both games
i was winning
against some it wasn't easy but against
alex i saw the win and i just
got confused myself and
i couldn't
couldn't you know convert it
and yeah like if i won these two games i
have one extra points to the situation
right now it's totally different even
after i lost to fabi so you know he
could have gone either way but
sometimes it's just like that so i'm
i'm happy definitely that i could
you know
play those games because i know like
that you know sometimes my conversion
of advantages requires more precision so
i will have to pay into this
pay more more uh attention to this
detail in my my future games you
anticipated my question in fact
what have you learned tell us one thing
you've learned from this event you
talked about the importance of the
conversion yeah of advantages how do you
train for that as a player on your level
it's very hard to train for it because
usually what we do is just try to get
some advantage of the opening and
this is pretty much where it ends
of course there's some calculation
training and so on but this aspect is
pretty pretty tricky because i mean
it's not something you look at at the
first time at the first instance but i
think that what would help me with some
training games with some you know better
positions trying to win them
some maybe against other players uh i'm
not sure if there will be enough time
before my next tournament but
you know
for the future future like definitely i
will look into that i'm going to give
you some advice uh hurry up order yasser
sarwan's book on amazon and go over his
best game
you have a very very promising uh future
you know the guys
caspar
he has beaten citadel
he's got one or two all right well it's
good to know that you are keeping good
spirits and focus on your last game good
luck thanks
good luck also in the phoenix
championship thanks yes first of all
very good luck at the riga uh fide
championship in the
in your campaign to qualify for the
candidates um
this particular event we've seen we've
seen u.s championships in the past sam
shanklin winning plus six fabiano with
plus five clear second uh we've seen big
scores we're seeing a monster score in
the women's section with carissa
this year's u.s championship
plus two is leading the whole field is
this a surprise to you it is a surprise
yeah definitely i wasn't expecting that
i was thinking that you know we like
plus three plus four maybe
not maybe plus five but plus four i was
sort of expecting
but uh i don't know it is the way it is
sometimes
yeah
maybe a tiredness by the top players
they're playing quite a lot of events uh
these days
i don't know to be honest
to me it seems like
the level is just very very even
sometimes you know worse positions that
are there uh
like i had very tough pushing against
jeffrey as well and i managed to hold it
right so um
you know like also against me players
managed to hold so basically the level
is very you know even and people try to
players try to fight ld and until
basically there is nothing to hope for
right so that's what makes the game
tough sometimes one inaccuracy is enough
for someone to save the game thank you
for your insights and good luck tomorrow
thanks and hopefully we're not born
stupid and dicey
what kind of saying is it
don't bring that one to america
no more stupid in your dice
one of the games that it's about to uh
finish is the one between ray robson and
uh john burke because it seems like john
found a way of forcing eliminate all the
pots well forcing the pawns to advance
faster than he was
if he could put his king on f3 in this
exact position
uh then he's got chances of nursing
probably winning that one uh but the
problem was
knight takes c5 right now he's going to
come on the board
that's the problem and there is no way
that you can save that second pawn and
you're not going to be able to beat me
with only one pawn so the point is
knight takes e5 right here right now
f4 takes e5
rook g5 with the double attack against
the both the pawns you would love to be
able to uh by king f4
king to f4 or rook to e4 defending both
pawns but unfortunately that's not
possible theater rules don't allow that
and after knight takes so this is the
current position and this is the moment
that john burke
is waiting for knight takes uh if i
actually have that
position position right now oh that's
not the game
ray rob said john burke yeah
by the way fabi
i mean he's got it all wrapped up he's
cruising bit wrapped look the pawn on f4
is hanging at some point he's going to
play g5 right you are frozen you are
locked
in prison and it's just me bringing more
ammunition to take care of business and
sooner or later this bishop will show up
this king could even dance and prance
the f6
and then this d-pawn will hang the p-91
is always going to happen this
construction cannot hold together and
fabi will find a way to break in and
he'll be patient and determined he
already knows the other results have all
fallen his way right there were five
other players for him to think about
five of them three ahead of him two
beside him the two beside him
i've drawn well we're going to call the
robson game a clear draw right and the
three i've had
also the two i had two at him also drew
and one he's playing and he's going to
win this game incredible the entire
script written in his favor and all he
has to do is win at which point he'll
say i'm tied this is like the tournament
just started i'm tired with everybody
at this top position it'd actually only
be a three-way tie for first
only
a three-way tie in which he will be one
of them standing atop
the mountain you're right incredible for
him and he i'm sure the first sentence
to come out of his mouth would be man i
had such a bad tournament and i'm still
typing first like wow what a chance what
an incredible chance right now
that he has we'll see if he can close
the deal and how are the pairings for
tomorrow looking like that's what i
wanted to ask you maybe we can get the
graphic hit that one because don't be
looking at me i know fabiano is playing
he's playing
with the wisely plays down in the last
round that i know wesley
a better player also with the white
pieces also but a better pairing here it
is
fabi versus sam bruzan lenderman
bruzon lenderman dominguez versus uh
zverev dominguez is no longer in
contention where he is
he's a half a point behind he has a
point behind
the trio the trinity
versus
jeffrey shang right wesley sew is
playing ray robson
with white pieces
sam can hunt him down and try to
also control his own destiny a win there
guarantees a playoff at least wow
any one of those players there are none
of them playing each other they're all
across purposes and they also know that
if they only draw well first of all they
might not who can wrote the script but
then there's nothing behind them so it's
it's uh it's all to play for
uh right now and this although there
could only be a five-way tie at max now
five-way tie
is is playing
uh with uh wesley yep right
wow very very invaluable penultimate
round but we need a break we will take a
short break don't go anywhere and we'll
come back with the final moments of
these games
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end has
established itself as a premier global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the us
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the u.s and world chess halls
of faint
cutting edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect and everything you love three
different galleries and a premier gift
shop highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess leave enriched
to learn more about the st louis chess
campus visit stlchestcampus.org
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to our continuous
coverage here at the us chess
championships we are in round number 10
which is almost over yasser during the
break what happened some dramatic
results and here we go uh as a draw was
reached between ray robson and john
burke but look at the sam shanklin and
naruto sam shanklin won his game against
and we have only one game pending that's
the big clash but that's a completely
winning position for fabio it looks like
it lenderman versus fabiano we're going
to have to wait and see what the final
result will be in that one in the latest
section
almost all the games are done two are
still pending shari vish versus foy sure
and nemtsova versus tokyo giornova a lot
of decisive games today three
so far absolutely and we do have one
guest in the studio who is with maurice
ashley tatev abrahamian after a
beautiful victory
a beautiful finish to be sure
yesterday's victory was quite dominant
with the white pieces again you had the
white pieces and this time you decided
i'm not going to play e4 let's go back
to one that serves you well knight f3
how did that work out this time well i
have 100 score with night after
i think it's my best opening so far uh
she just got into really bad time
troubles i think when you have that
little time any position is tough to
play
and then obviously okay like rook c6
groups that do that she went for it just
looking for some kind of activity after
just like shuffling for a while
it looked like she actually just
blundered in this position an unusual
blender to be short looks like after
takes uh allowing takes you had this
beautiful knight e1 and suddenly the
rook is getting mated yeah when i went
a5 i saw this and i thought she'll
probably go for it because it feels like
she was looking for activity getting a
bit impatient
so
i guess a bit of a triumph
indeed a study like trap
your score is not what you were hoping
for as far as the beginning of the
tournament but it seems that you picked
up the pace and is doing quite well of
late
i think i'm at 50 percent
i mean okay considering how i started
this is a pretty decent result you saw
how carissa did in the tournament what's
your impression she beat four former
champions won five in a row just one of
the given that you played in a lot of
championships one of the all-time great
performances in the tournament she
clinched already yes she has oh okay no
i thought she played really well she's
definitely deserve a champion i think
she's the best player here
so i it's not surprising at all
all right well thanks for sharing your
thoughts and good luck in your last game
thank you thank you tata good luck
indeed as we have two games remaining in
the women's section how is your charge
student doing uh well the game she uh
built up a very nice advantage out of
the opening and right now she's fighting
to convert
it's not an easy conversion and we've
seen him in this type of situation this
is not her first rodeo no she's facing
this type of blow case we've seen the
game between her and uh sabina foyshore
which ended in a draw okay then we saw
yesterday's game against nazi pakis that
looked like a blockade for a while she
managed to break through okay now we're
seeing something very very similar but
she's got the two bishops against the
two knights
and
the pawns are doubled that's the problem
ooh
this move
the knights are
trapped
i don't like this move by katya she
caught herself she had reached for the
night
she played the knight to a4 and after
king b5 i think that just finishes that
unbelievable mistake right that's sorry
blunder that she's fall she's collapsing
now that's the howler because guess what
bishop f8 once that move appears on the
board
a piece drops well you can go knight to
uh king to d4 threatening the move
knight to c3 but now i just pick up the
f4 the next pawn no that's bishop takes
f4 and that's it you're going to give me
a check i'm going to drop back but now
it's a completely different story i have
an extra point free pawn for no reason
that is definitely and
she's going for an incredible blunder oh
she had the lead then she lost the lead
with only a draw but still had a good
result then she lost the game
and now it's the wheels have come off
the bus and tomorrow she's facing
carissa yep with the black pieces oh
which carissa might just give her a gift
of a draw in that situation
or or a charism
i don't i don't see why she would do
that no no she does she would not need
to carissa can play for it can carissa
win six in a row we don't have a name
for winning six in a row wow
great
big overview
thank you thank you very much no by the
way i'm gonna claim it as an original
yeah
we have witnesses we have witnesses and
we have nobody
i don't know because there's a woman's
grand prix as well of course that
qualifies the candidates and i think
it's happening at the same time
she would probably be
the representative for the u.s i'd love
to see her represent i'm just wondering
how that will look so if that's the case
well of course the school studies is one
thing but this is an opportunity to
qualify for the kansas tournament it's a
big opportunity i understand and she was
missing jennifer you because she's in
harvard they wouldn't give her
permission no and i know carissa is
graduating high school high school in
high school she's gonna make that up
right
okay
the way if carissa doesn't get accepted
to some top school as a result of
missing too many classes i'm sure
there's one place called mizzou
coached by one christian carillon
[Music]
you're my best recruiter maurice
nice uh
this is an important win for the prize
money for the podium standings and
if she wins this one um
nova will almost
guarantees a placement on the podium
and then tomorrow she will be fighting
for the second second place against
cervantes
well she'll have at least third and
she'll look for second and she's playing
for her debut she's rolling for her
debut fantastic pretty impressive and
there you go
yeah she's dropped the f4 pawn
come on because by these bishops guys
let's go back to uh fabiano
fabiano's game because this one is over
easily winning this one is over well
it's talking about easily winning i mean
this is total domination this was the
kind of position i thought i was amazed
when the computer was saying that there
was some ways for for for uh
alex to defend i don't see anything
other than you know just look at these
three pieces
was this rook b b1 the only move did he
have anything
other than that any other i'd be shocked
if there was
anything myself i'm just saying
95 i think now bishop f7 is on the board
please focus on that
lasering that pawn on d5 well you want
to play f3 but there is the slight
accident that there the king happens to
be on the same f file so let's move
bishop f7
uh as a prelude to playing the move f3
that's going to
cause
that yeah
that is just ouch
wow what a dramatic game this was though
mike
extraordinary the fact that we got a
chance to breathe was really important
because we would have had a heart attack
if they just kept going it was such an
exciting game
and and it and it shows and he made that
mistake that critical mistake where he
missed rook to b3 and he's given fabi
this chance by the way he's been
thinking for a long time so only down to
six minutes and 37 seconds is lenderman
and 656 for fabi his only chance
lenderman is somehow fabi
lets the time slip away completely but
his moves are so strong fabi now at 7
20. thanks to the 30-second increment
black's position is so strong so
dominating so
so every which way
queen d4 played
that's
also the tournament situation the
resurgence of fabiano caruana incredible
this felt like one of the most tense
games that i've uh called in a long time
i agree i mean this reminds us exactly
that one is over because this one is
over
i mean i'm thinking of the sh shaq
that was the game that maurice
referenced as one of the most exciting
things for that one everything it was a
sink field
no it wasn't it wasn't one that would
win the tournament it was certainly
early on in the event but it didn't
matter this the stakes here of course
makes this a much bigger game right but
in that game we we were just
on the skates
and wobbly and what's going to happen
next and what a move and it was simply
incredible and as yasser mentioned one
second when rapport made his move and
only at once
we we felt every bit of the excitement
of that one and then the fantastic
finish
as well i remember
knocked him out
at the very end that was dramatic we we
we live for those kinds of games as
commentators this certainly had it at
the time control
yeah and
yeah then i mean in terms of drama that
was just fast fantastic game to call
um
ray robson we we we left it at the
bishop sacrifice the next thing we did
is we came back at the ending in the
basement with us uh discussing his game
with john burke okay and that ended you
know in a draw right but that had some
flair going too it did it did and of
course it was ray who infused that with
his sacrifice
calculating all of that it felt like a
very tense game uh as well he wasn't
managed to uh he didn't manage to break
through wow
hard to win games you know his
uh us championships i must say yes uh
lanier dominguez also he's on the
outside looking at as we're looking at
alex
he must be kicking himself out for
missing that huge opportunity yesterday
against ray robinson exactly and alex
lenderman comes into today's game
undefeated in a tie for first at the
trinity on top looks like he's going to
be uh
changing places trading places that was
the still has a chance
still has a chance he loses this game
he's only
half a point out of hers
but he's going to play with the black
but he's going to have i'm not hey again
why are you trying to reign on his
brother
all i'm saying is he still has a chance
right he will be with the black pieces
there will be a gaggle of players three
players who is he playing against linear
right is is it linear if he has
black he can forget about it
you weren't just making the case for him
no more
but but that would be a huge game
because lanier has a chance right and
lanier knows if there are draws at the
top he can pull a fobby and join them
with a win so therefore lanier versus
lenderman will be a dog fight as lanier
will give it his all and it will give
lenderman a chance in case lanier
overpresses at that moment to
potentially go up there as well so
that that matchup is huge lindemann
versus
versus uh dominguez flipped that dominus
versus lenderman no question about it
but we do have a guest in the studio who
is with maurice gulroch begin
after a beautiful victory in her clash
with katherine and soa
yes and congratulations on that victory
you've won a few games in a row is it
three in a row now
three in a row so you're pulling a mini
carissa but as you know she has won the
tournament with her performance but this
is a big win for you that guarantees you
at least a tie for third no matter what
happens how do you feel about the way
the game transpired
actually it's good i guess and overall
i played a good tournament and good game
so far
so
i mean we came here to win the
tournament of course that's why i'm
i'm not that happy with my performance
because i know that i could do much
better according to positions as well so
it's still fine i'm glad
that i could
at least win a couple of games in the
end
your position in the opening she seemed
to just come after you with some
original play with c3 you started with
knight d7 in the opening and then she
played this idea with c3 and took on d5
with the queen instead of taking with
the knight on c3 were you surprised at
that moment the way she was playing c3
was surprising and i didn't check this
line with c3 and
during the game i realized oh my god i
missed this move like i didn't check it
but in general black should be fine i
didn't see any problems maybe for me it
would be a little bit better to play
knight
b d
db8 instead of knight c5 i would just be
pawn up there without like
um
any counter play i guess but um
loves your move knight c5 but my
position would be so passive that's why
i really didn't want to go there yeah
yeah your engine the engine loves knight
c5 they think but after knight c5 that
position it was very hard to play with
black i guess i had to be very very
precise luckily she didn't make the best
moves i guess
all these moves the engine loves by the
way your retreating moves were perfect
and precise as you mentioned
it was here you you had a knight
like
before g4 or a4 but i just wanted to uh
exchange all the rooks that's why i put
rook design first i thought okay she's
gonna play four and i'm playing id a4 i
thought this version is better but then
i realized that she has to take on this
summon and play rook b1
maybe it would be a little bit better
for her okay the position is worse but
still
better attempts you're saying yeah and
maybe she could take actually earlier on
c6
when i played castle she could take on
c6 and then
beat btex c6 queen c6 rook b8 and queen
c2
instead of uh
after castle and i think this is the
line that you mentioned
instead of knight to c3 on c6
she could she could definitely but it's
still better for black yeah it's still
better i have two bishops but i thought
maybe it's better for her to play this
position
but she was trying to like win uh no
matter what that's why she played this
kind of opening and she didn't like the
idea of exchanging some pieces i guess
that's
it was strange the way she played when
she took on d5 for sure instead of
playing with with knight takes on c3
and
psychologically for her it was difficult
because she'd been leading the
tournament for so long and suddenly she
was on her back foot she was
i don't think she was leading you don't
think she was leading you want to do
commentary for us
no carissa was leading no
no katarina was leading the tournament
all the way through
through seven rounds uh it's when she
got passed by carissa only then she was
plus three
with no losses i mean she hasn't played
me and karissa and crush at that point
right exactly she ended up having a
tough road at the very finish and that's
what has cost her uh so
you basically have uh not the victory to
play for another top result how do you
approach this last game
i'm just gonna do my best and that's all
as usual i really enjoy playing and it's
an amazing opportunity because i have
school
and i don't have that much time to play
chess so i have been enjoying whole
tournaments and
i hope that i will play a good game
tomorrow as well all right well good
luck with that one we'll see you
tomorrow thank you very good luck
congratulations and we're going to
return to the fabi game because it's all
important is it really what has happened
when we left it we were right here we
saw the move queen d4 alex played rook d
juan
uh doing his best to make uh fabby's
life his definition takes
g7
i kind of like that move actually that
bishop takes d5 you thought it was even
more taught
okay i understand what he wants to do so
he wants to take on d5 why did he gonna
do it originally and he didn't do it
originally because he was calculating
bishop takes e5 bishop takes d5 queen d5
king g1 okay and now i would assume he
wants to have the move rook to g3 on tap
with the king on f8 you can just simply
take with a queen on g how
embarrassingly would that be the rook
the pawn being pinned to the king and
right now alex goes for h4 trying to
open up the position creates some sort
of counter chances on that side he had
only 55 seconds left by the way he had
to just make a move did alex when he
played h4 bobby was over five minutes on
his clock so down to 125 is linderman
after this move and bobby with five
minutes plus of course the game has no
stop time at all no no stopping number
of moves it's not like it's 20 moves in
30 minutes it's the rest of the game
that they're playing on increments right
now but fabi has complete control h4
really doesn't do anything to slow down
the momentum that black
has developed so we'll see
fabi is just making sure before he takes
his pawn on d5
as alex knows he's in dire straits and
again fabi has how much time four
minutes and 40 seconds okay
now you know winning technique and
everything like that and i love that
pawn on d5 i truly do
but now that the pawn is on g4 all
alone
and the h file is is potentially coming
open i like
getting my knight back to e5 i love
getting my knight back to e5 so i can
take the pawn on g4 so
my instinct would be to play queen f6
followed by knight e5 yeah i understand
that you could just take on d5
and just finish potentially the game off
you're going to sit for a while and
think about which one to play
no i'm just saying i play queen f6 and
knight e5 right away i just i i don't
like being in pins even when i'm playing
bishop dxd5 i don't like being in the
pin and as good as the knight
visually looks on d3
on the e5 square it would be
hitting g4 which is just a huge pawn it
would be protecting the king the queen
is a dream boat position on f6 as well
for queen to c4 he went queen c4 because
he might just have too many moves that's
the problem too
i mean he's ready to look at he's gonna
he's getting ready to go 95 but he's
also eyeballing this rook with his queen
still on the fourth rank it's a great
move but still i mean to play a bravado
move like this one
and your opponent has no time by the way
i mean that just makes it worse and
worse for for whites for white white's
plan at that point white house would
only be rook to a2 and try to get the
rook to
the seventh rank and potentially create
some sort of bishop takes you protects
the square you were there you were there
so i'm just saying that if i go queen
back and you go rook a2 and i go knight
e5 and you put your rook on a7
you had been there a moment ago and g4 i
was
yeah variation though oh sorry it's to
take on a take on g5 and then take on d3
oh and bishop to e4 and i get the check
you get it i get one check one check
double rooks on the board this is
getting a little bit more complicated
well i mean it's
it's looking
i mean when you double your rooks on the
d file as white in this position
you know
something's wrong right i mean the rooks
don't belong doubled on the default
night
knight to e1 right now
you're seeing knight e1 i just want to
target that bishop on g2 and then take
on d5
i'm feeling a little uncomfortable i'm
playing five
this is the boss move i get you i get
you i just want to make sure he gets the
job done
i like maurice is actually a very honest
man he'll tell you why do you like to
play i pick the guy what are you talking
about all right just keep it up oh boy
capture gain 30 seconds and by the way
once again h
he lifted up the h pawn and then he took
the pawn on g5 as did bobby so
it seems bobby doesn't do that in blitz
by the way
he goes hg5 where's he takes it right
right you might especially one minute
blitz and this is the problem the by the
way the rook side and d5 on
the knight
eyeballing the e5 g4 pawn pardon me once
again
uh it's resigns as long as you're down a
queen
black feels good
that's one way of putting it i mean
you're down a queen and you can do it
all right on a queen you're down a queen
yeah your queen has no prospects on the
h5 no it doesn't root d4 had to make a
move
attack something as big as a queen why
not and by the way queen back goes back
to c3 and thank you for putting your
your rook oh by the way
we need to do queen takes g4 oh of
course of course i i that we need to
i mean i was just thinking that the you
know sometimes when you're it's an
impossible position for white exactly
exactly you guys were saying that queen
c3 he's not playing without he's playing
without his queen he's playing without
all of his pieces right it's got two
rooks dancing around that are doing
absolutely nothing that's the whole
they're just defensive no it's that's
too good
that wasn't the most accurate move by
the way queen c3 by fabi but it will be
good enough there is a random rook sack
on f4 possible right now right going
down material
and fabi can just trade all the pieces
off and go into an easily winning
position so that maybe what we see is
down to 19 seconds
and it's just so hopeless
that what are you supposed to do
13
and ticking and alex just can't believe
it
that he's at this stage of the game six
seconds five and he's about to move his
queen and he's put it on g1 queen to g1
yikes
yikes shakes
i'm trying to figure out what trap he
might be setting
and i don't that's uh what's what's uh
where's the trap that's a challenge
there is no trap
this one would be interesting if he
could somehow move his bishop out of the
way just simply knight takes you and get
an attack on this knight on g4 all the
way to the king and i think bobby
doesn't believe it bobby said i'm taking
it i don't see where your bishop goes
because we're okay
so looking at the location h3 rook h3
check is just too strong
there's no defense there's no way to
move the bishop out of the way to get
there you have to go queen to f1 at this
point
ooh yeah well what what can i say to
that
uh
no this is over
and it's been over one d2
and by the way is it time for rook h3
so rgd2 wants to cover
with that rook on h2 after rook to h3
has a clear idea in mind
but there has to be a tactic right now
well i'm yes no question about it there
definitely has to be a tactic right now
what about root g3 right now that's so
easy just to have a little fun that
looks great
tie everybody down
so let's just see
if you don't mind i just want to have a
look-see rook h3 again i mentioned it a
a time ago a kind of a benoni player's
dream that sometimes in these endings
your king makes a quick walk
to the e5 square
and uh
so how do you want to finish me off
exactly that situation exactly yes sir
yes yes sir may i since that one yes i'm
gonna still be working yes what about
rook e8
just
that is a nice move because you've got
queen coming to g3 you got rook coming
to h8
that's a nice move just again how do you
finish this off i'll take the queen in
that place
in that case takes queen looks well
that's pretty good
that's a finisher
that felt like the gatorade reminiscent
of king age two that fabiano played
against john burke
almost the same it's time to resign oh
rookie
c8 with the same idea oh
wait a minute but i had the queen
guarding the e3 square right
and g3 and everything fobby
but this is
that's
that one looks pretty good too let's see
jeffrey's young that beautiful queen h
you guys are going to come around to my
retreating movies they were talking
about wait a minute we're going to a1
and now we're going to queen a1 the
checkmating sequence
queen by fabiano caruana
and rook to f3 has is that it rook to f3
what is that well we just dropped the
queen in first of all we post up
and then we say okay how do
how do we finish the game
there is a discover check in the
position that we have to be
very mindful of i don't know no no rook
f3 is just waiting right what rook f3
bishop f3 knight d3
king g1 queen g1 you want to take that
and i just take the queen oh that's so
boring that no that's weird
you just you just took my queen why
can't christian
show so he went for it yeah
might as well i mean there goes the lady
and by the way i'm not i'm coming back
for more queen f1 and he's done it rook
f3 he sees it and he's going to machine
like and he's got knights go after it on
the board too why did the why did the
engine just do something crazy i i must
be taking it
joking
g1 is on the board king to e2 and after
the queen falls we're going to see a
resignation no way that's equal there's
no way
the
queen takes queen and that should be all
she wrote what to do here you're down
it's a piece and two pawns and
resignation i've got a theory
it's been such a dramatic game that the
engine's heart stopped
that's my theory and i'm sticking with
wow amazing he was dead he was minus one
he had lost two games in a row six
rounds in how is it that he is standing
atop the leaderboard with two other
players right now
incredible and the first defeat of
alexander lindemann in the tournament by
anyone it took fabi to win two in a row
to make the comeback real
boy wow look at the
trio at the top going into the final
championship round we have fabiano
carawanna wesley so and sam savion
wesley is almost like a prophet he said
plus tournament is going to be one with
plus three
are we going to see that tomorrow right
now this could be the case too
i used to call them the holy trinity the
hikaru nakamura wesley so fabiano at the
top of american chess
sam savion taking the role of ikaro as a
trio at the top lanier dominguez blowing
his win yesterday and only drawing today
couldn't join this
and ray robson could not win his game
either again so we have three players at
the top
well we expected two of those faces yes
we didn't think plus two would be it
though going into the last round it has
not been the case in recent u.s
championships
but fabi is back he's surging he's
playing the best chess of anyone right
now maybe not perfect chess but the most
enterprising and certainly the most
clutch
who had to win
and out of the last four games he's
three and a half half
that's that's playing like a boss yeah
that's saying i need to come back and
he's done so and the rest of the players
they're not showing anything special
none of them showing anything special
like he is right now he's surging and i
think wesley's going
darn it oh dear why did he have to show
up one more game left
in this one game remaining anna is down
upon against uh sabine but she's got
everything perfect for a draw because
her king will be heading over to the age
file an easy draw
uh and i
think the players will start looking for
a repetition although we have seen
sabina play on and on and on and on
sabino will be playing a number of her
games um
so uh we could be here a while guys but
i i just have to say
uh as you were saying uh maurice it's
amazing a big shout out to to fabi it
seems when his back is really against
the wall and he absolutely has to
produce he was down yeah he was dumb he
was he was in the
is a good move
anything anything okay
i think sabine is ready to take the draw
she just played h5 chuck
lots of checks is the way to go nothing
to do and here's check number one
i think we're going to see this game and
very soon she's not going to pretend no
this penultimate round
i mean a big
shout out to the players they gave us
everything we wanted and jerry's getting
the repetition and a great uh shout out
to carissa who are 18 years young is our
new u.s women's champion
coveted a title
for the ladies
and just great just this has been great
i also i want to
we're going to do it all and thank
everybody on the show but uh i think
that the coverage that we've managed to
achieve
with the video
all the audio work all the graphic work
has been world-class just world-class i
mean you guys should be
should be uh calling the world
championship well we will be thanking
the producer and everybody involved in
the production of this and there is the
handshake as the penultimate round is in
the country books that is it
wow wow a round yoster fabiano caruana
essaying the king's indian defense it
seems like a charge that's his opening
whenever he needs a victory he he watch
victory he's got a number yeah that one
yeah he's got the number the bononi he
loves the benoni right kings indian
defense even some crazy slobs i've seen
him play with like it was a game from
the singful cup with lavona roni and
some really really double-edged
sloth he's got a you've got a wide
rapper train let's give credit where
credit is due alex lenderman after
allowing fabiano to take on c3 which was
definitely not the right decision he
defended like a monster fought back with
queen c2 rook a3
wrap up our show uh we gotta wait for
five oh well
yeah well
[Applause]
[Laughter]
let's take a look at the final results
let's look at the final results we have
wesley so
sam savion and fabiano caruana tied
at
the lead we have lanier dominguez alex
slenderman and ray robson all of them
chances as well going behind
a chance not a lot of points they will
want to see the yeah and the tomorrow
the pairings it's all important because
our three leaders the player the group
behind our three leaders want to see
draws and by the way we were saying that
dominguez is playing lender and that's
not the case dominguez will be playing
darius virg caruana versus shankland
and wesley so versus ray robson
narudinsky versus sam savion john burke
versus jeffrey sean and bruzon versus
lenderman and we see two of those
leaders playing with the white pieces
fabiano and wesley so sam savion with
the black pieces but he is playing
narutiski who is struggling in this
event absolutely
four four points uh
has and the
women's final results for round ten or
the current standing sessions well we
have a champion
yip is our 2021 u.s women's chess
champion
irina crush and gulrukh begin to
hironova still fighting for
those playman placements on the podium
second and third position katharina
nemtsova still within striking distance
to the two ladies
one of our women's pairings for tomorrow
as you mentioned they're fighting for
the podium absolutely we have megan lee
versus anna sharovich irina crush versus
tatev abrahamian tohir genova versus
cervantes carissa yip against katarina
nemtsova zatonski versus spykidze and
sabina feuscher versus ashrita eswar all
right very very nice
well we do have a guest
yes we are with us here's with maurice
ashley fabiano caruana the man of the
hour
indeed the world number two
showing why he is such a boss winning on
demand fabi i was one point in this
tournament you were at minus one and
honestly there was dirt being put on on
the coffin
now somehow you have
just surged back into a tie for first
could you have imagined this scenario
just four rounds ago
no i was uh not thinking about being in
first place or playing for the
first place
after i lost two games in a row but
before today's game i was optimistic
because it felt like the trend was kind
of
improving in my tournament
um
i mean i really thought that this is
maybe not a must-win but pretty close to
a must-win game
uh because okay i mean counting on
tomorrow my fate isn't in my hands even
if i win tomorrow and draw this game
um
and that's why i play the kings indian
but it was a crazy game i i i didn't
expect it to go this way it was
and
maybe at someone i was sure i was losing
um
someone i was sure i was winning too
like much earlier on then i thought i'd
mess it up and i was like very close to
losing
um
and then after the time control i
thought i'm for sure winning but it was
still super difficult to keep it under
control yeah we needed the heart
defibrillator for yasser this one me too
let's go to the moment you had when you
played rook takes on c3 if you can bring
that up yesterday please rook c3 you
seem to pause at this point it's a point
where we were thinking fabi's just gonna
sack why did you hesitate at all here
did i think for so it wasn't that long
but we just thought you'd be just
eager to imbalance the position of work
c3 well i think is rook c3 is looks like
a no-brainer but he did play knight f3
the movie four he invited me to do this
and he had other moves like queen b3 or
something i thought that was his first
intention
um
because it looks really annoying the
point is 96 is the red not queen b7 but
knight e6
and so i have to stop at queen e7 and
it's a pawn sack like he takes on b7 i
play knight c5 i get the two bishops
i was pretty happy about this outcome
because i really have tremendous
compensation
but i mean i didn't expect him to allow
the exchange snack so that's why i
thought i mean
he's he's allowing it head-on i have to
think about
um you know what he has in mind because
obviously he he considered it
um
so at least i in any way it's useful
because i'm going i'm going to use the
calculation that i do here later on
um and i thought his moves were forced
queen c2 knight d2
i wasn't sure about my moves but i i
thought
i mean i have so many options i should
kind of keep keep the pace of it because
he was playing quite quickly
and so then you played b5 and all heck
broke loose right here when you play
knight to d3 queen b1 not being the best
defense
yeah right here you must have just
thought okay i'm rocking and rolling
yeah well when i played knight d3 i had
this qu this knight before in mind
um
he has other moves but queen b1 uh
is a very logical one
because he doesn't care about f2 he just
wants to take on b5 and all my pieces
will be hanging
and i before i was happy with and i
thought c before knight f2 like i'm not
sure if i'm
much better or winning but i don't see a
move for him so
at least it's pleasant to give yeah this
is mate bishop d4
um
like he the problem is that like once my
queen gets to the diagonal it's just a
mating attack
um after i get rid of his bishop
and then he quickly played rook a5 i
thought this can't be good
uh queen c3 and i expected knight f3
which i thought can't be good but it's
still a lot to calculate with limited
time and then he played bishop b3 and i
thought
like everything must be winning but
but i got very confused and i ended up
going for something which
was certainly not winning yeah bishop
takes g3 was the best move according to
the engine yeah i think i thought if he
gets like rook a3 mike
would i just go to e5
um
yeah this was probably very simple and i
i should have
not
you know
not overthought it and just played a
simple move but i really thought bishop
v4 might just be winning on the spot
because of f4
and then after g4 i didn't see anything
right now he was suddenly back in the
struggle yeah and then i i was also
getting low on time so i
i thought yeah
like after
queen g1 which i missed i was suddenly
worried that i'm like almost losing
um which i see the bar now it says it's
not the case
but but you know it's it's a bit scary
because knight f3 um i mean i'm also
getting under attack and i i don't have
like an obvious next move so i was happy
to find this king of f8 h6 because
h6 was really important i need to stop
my g5
um
here the engine after 8 16 g5
yeah i wasn't
oh well the move i was happy with is a
mistake
[Laughter]
to start with i thought h5 is not like a
bat
out yeah now my king gets under now your
king is trapped i think yeah maybe rook
b7 now because suddenly
uh my king can't escape like it could in
the game with king of six
but uh i think we were both a bit too
short on time to figure out the position
right exactly now it got just super
sharp
and then you got to
it was clear at his time control that
there was a problem because he just
started
you could sense he was very nervous and
he played defensively at this point
instead of being as aggressive as he
could although he was putting up a very
heroic defense at some point
and he why did you play rookie five in
our rookie three i thought he'll expect
rookie three
ah i wasn't sure which was better
um but rookie five looked like
the thing is i threatened to take but
it's not really clear if i am always
going to threaten to take like after
rook v8 and here i i'm going to try to
take with check or queen c3 and
queen of three so i thought
it was more important to have that
queen um
the queen threatening f3 rather than the
rook but i don't know i i mean
um
for sure we were making mistakes
right yeah rookie three was stupid
because i should have played knight d3
and then we get the game which is
probably winning for blacks yes
we were very surprised he didn't play
were you worried he might guess the move
knight d3 at this point
well i don't know that wasn't it it's
just that after rookie three rook i
thought maybe
i wasn't sure if knight d3 worker for
rookie three was was really very good
for black it's only after time control
that i realized he has almost no moves
um
so
so i thought maybe after a workout when
there was like rook takes f3 which
doesn't quite work out um and queen d5
i think that one uh he has this um
queen g2 move maybe right before is also
a draw
uh quincy well queen g2 might just be
winning so that's a bit of an issue
[Laughter]
nicely put
british understatement no maybe not
maybe 93 maybe i keep it together but uh
but anyway this is not what i i want
right exactly
and it was only after time control did
he finally make the fun the blunder
which was yeah he played this so quickly
but i
the queen is bad on g2 because it runs
into 91. right i think he was thinking
that after like queen c3 he could move
his bishop somewhere it should be four
but then okay he has no squares for his
bishop because rook h3
and queen h3 knight of two wins
um which is maybe not even necessary but
i think that was the only explanation i
had
um
for why he played it so quickly i think
we thought the rook b3 was his last best
chance of being able to defend the
position yeah it might not be
um so clear-cut maybe white can hold it
but it's not a fun i mean rugby three is
a really tough move it's totally tough
to find queen and after queen c3 now you
were completely in the driver's seat and
dominated it's like after
uh i mean there was so much to calculate
yeah 95 and an h4 like i couldn't yeah
h4 i wasn't
h4 here yeah the thing is i thought
knight g4 right rook f4 king g8 would
win
um wow and it's important rook of fate
take queen e6 king james my king is
covered
but then i realized um
yeah this wins for black he has no more
checks
but then i realize after knight g4 he
can take
rookie one
oh sorry uh after knight g4 no rook four
king g8 take one g4
rook g4
rookie one and uh bishop f1 loses
because of queen f3 this is actually
quite important
um
but he had just has queen g1 and
surprisingly his pieces are loose but i
don't
have a way to use them
um
take take and his work on g4 my king is
is again in a mating nut i mean not not
yet now but potentially
so i thought this is maybe just not
better for not so easy at all or yeah
definitely not easy so i wasn't going to
play that i was going to play h4 um
h4 f3
hg king g8
this is like my backup
but he plays bishop h3
now i take on g5 and uh my opponent f3
is is kind of blocking my attack a bit i
mean he's still probably in bad shape
but it's not
uh
not an easy one not i mean this was a
good chance for him
so knight e5 was was a serious mistake i
guess
all right but he didn't find those
defenses he allowed you yeah this wasn't
just very bad
in the position
and you eventually got everything you
possibly want
and this final retreating move with the
queen
uh one one little point here rook brook
e8 was also playable
is there a defense to that
uh yeah i haven't seen it
that's the difference
i didn't see it okay i'll pat myself on
the back for fighting and move uh
every once in a while a blind squirrel
friday night
i i saw this queen c8 and the line would
um which happened in the game and uh
and it was enough to say
don't need more than one win in chess
one win per game
per game is all you get yeah you tried
to find all the wins in in the final
position then you'd you'd be there all
day you know i think that's important
all moves are winning
well
you are
tied for first
i don't think you could say that since
round two
one
round
probably round four
round four yeah there was a point where
before you lost when i was plus one i
think it was no no one was
because i know because ray robson wasn't
clear first okay in round four so it
must have been by round three that you
were not not i i three i drew all my all
my games at the start and then i
oh you oh i i won my third one i won my
third you're right you know what yeah
don't try to
test the commentary
we follow you just make all the good
moves but you were you were a tie for
first at one point and then ray did his
thing and then you slipped out now
suddenly you find yourself in the last
round you've got white against
sam against sam who just won his game
all out
i mean
not all out when you're in the lead you
don't necessarily have to go all out
also sam is not a player who that
strategy will necessarily work against
um
but
i mean i will try of course all right
well well done to get to this point uh
i'll remind you that i picked you to win
the tournament so if that helps
i already picked carissa to win
thank you guys say say say yeah say it
go
our life has gone down dramatically
they're not happy you're right they're
not happy but you know so far i'm right
so the trend is your way
good luck in your last game thank you
good luck
really really really well done fantastic
as you say a phoenix rising from the
ashes that's uh an apt metaphor to
describe his return to the podium wow
but nothing is over yasser tomorrow we
have the championship round right that
is it we have crown one champion and
here she is our 2021 u.s women's chess
champion karissa yip who just simply
dominated the field with a bingo with a
bingo five wins in a row and the
coverage will continue tomorrow with
round number 11 our championship round
championship monday and if we do need
the playoffs those are going to be
played on tuesday october 19th at pm
central time there's one announcement
regarding the closing ceremony that
closing ceremony we were going to induct
in the world chess hall of fame three
nominees including judith polgar
judith polgar and eugene torre but we
have postponed that induction until the
karen's cup so that both judith and
eugene can just be there and then be
inducted into person so i really want to
thank the world chess hall of fame for
allowing that postponement a real big
shout out i look forward to seeing
judith and eugene and his wife marilyn
marilyn in person here in st louis
well maurice final thoughts after this
round
as a commentator you always love it when
you see something you've never seen
before
and we've never seen a woman dominate
by winning against four former champions
that's in the history of the u.s
championship the u.s women's
championship and
we ourselves have been calling a lot of
those tournaments so to see karissa do
that is just fabulous you can say while
i was there when it happened who knows
when it will happen again but she has
done it she did it in style kudos to her
that tournament is laid to rest who
knows what's going to happen tomorrow as
we've got three players tied at the top
and we still have chasers after them
this is what you want as a commentator
as well drama in the last round we get
it
you don't want to miss it absolutely
right
well it was a long day and we're going
to resume everything tomorrow at 1 00 pm
see you guys tomorrow good night
everyone
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club
any reproduction or distribution of this
content without the express written
consent of the st louis chess club is
prohibited
you